Ah, yes, exellent, aufwacht Champ. Leute, das mit dem Champ, das hat sich so eingebürgert
bei mir, irgendwie so eingeschliffen bei mir. Ich nenne mittlerweile auf der Arbeit, mittlerweile
schon irgendwelche komischen Programme, die ich mache, Champ hinten dran. Ich hab letztens
was gebastelt, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt hab. Das hab ich wahrscheinlich
schon 50 mal erzählt, weil ich das so geil fand. Irgendeiner auf der Arbeit hat, ist
egal wer, hat so eine Auswertung programmiert, um Zugriffe über einen Proxy zu zählen.
Also sprich, der hat quasi alle Log-Dateien genommen und hat die durchgekreppt, durchsucht
nach Aufrufen vom Squirt. Und dann hat er halt einfach gezählt, wie oft die Sachen vorkommen.
So, und das hat er in Bash gemacht, also Linux Shell. Und das lief, alter, das lief in der
Testumgebung, ne Woche, eine Woche lief die Log-Auswertung mit seinem Bash-Script. Muss
man sich mal vorstellen. So, und da hab ich mir gedacht, okay, das kann's jetzt ja nicht
sein. Also, hab ich ein.NET-Programm gebastelt, den Logchamp, wo wir auf dem Thema sind.
Also wie gesagt, ich nenne mittlerweile auf der Arbeit auch den ganzen Kram schon irgendwas
mit Champ. Und der Logchamp hat das gleiche dann gemacht, wie das Bash-Script und das
war in 15 Minuten. Sag mal, in der Testumgebung 15 Minuten und in der Live-Umgebung, würde
ich sagen, so 35 Minuten. Aber das sind ja auch wirklich massiv viele Logs gewesen. Hat
er in, sag mal mal, in einer halben Stunde 15 bis 30 Minuten durchsucht worden, da wäre
das Bash-Script wahrscheinlich einen Monat oder so gelaufen, keine Ahnung. Und das war
schon nice. Das hat natürlich den Server komplett dicht gemacht. Ich hab das Multi-Threaded eingestellt
und das lief halt auf 12 Kern. Also der Server hat 24, aber ich hab's auf 12 beschränkt.
Das Ding hat den Server komplett dicht gemacht, sogar so dicht, dass die Java-Anwendung da
drauf ab und zu hing, weil das Ding muss ab und zu mal Garbage collecten und da hat's nicht
genug CPU-Kerne für gehabt. Ich wusste auch nicht, dass es Java schafft 24 CPU-Kerne nur
mit Garbage-Collection auszulassen. Logs, Squid-Logs. So, Stripes, Dankeschön für den Sub, 20 Monate
Massive-Subscription. Dankeschön für den Sub. Leute, ich sag euch gleich, ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher, wie lange ich heute on bin. Ich hab nämlich Jübel's Kopfe seit 2 Tagen
und wenn ich mich hinlege, ist es besser. Ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt. Ich glaube,
es liegt daran, ich hab ja so meine Vermutung. Ich glaube, es liegt am Umbau von meinem Server-Raum,
weil ich bin da teilweise so ungelenkig ja mittlerweile. Ich bin da teilweise über Stunden
auf der Erde rumgekrochen, hab irgendwelche Dinger verlegt, Sachen an die Wand geschraubt
und hab schräg um die Ecke geguckt für 20 Minuten. Genau, eher Wub-Alt als Wub-Corona.
Der 3D-Drucker steht ja auch drinne, vielleicht hat es auch irgendwelche Ausdunstungen oder
so. Nee, aber ich glaube, es liegt daran. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt zu lange vorm Rechner
sitz, krieg ich Kopfweh. Ich merk's permanent immer so ein bisschen, aber nicht zu lange
vorm Rechner sitz. Es könnten natürlich auch 5G sein. Was meint ihr Leute? Liegt es daran,
dass ich mich doof bewegt habe oder meint ihr, es liegt an 5G? Was ist wahrscheinlicher?
Ah, dachte ich mir, dachte ich mir. Ich dachte, es muss 5G sein. Ich glaube, wir haben hier
noch nicht mal 5G empfangen. Aber es ist schon 5G. Liegt an der Impfung? Ich bin nicht dick
genug. Ich krieg keine Impfung. Leute, ich bin nicht pepo-fett genug. Man kriegt ab
einem BMI von 40, kriegt man die Impfung, wie glaube ich, ab 70-Jährige. So, es gibt
jetzt zwei Varianten. Entweder ich nehme ultra-schnell sehr viel zu, dass ich über einen BMI über
40 komme, oder ich lasse mich als Impfung-Mensch normal dran kommen. Ich fürchte, auf Dauer
gesünder ist, nicht zuzunehmen. Ich hatte eh letzten schon ein Problem. Ich habe letztens
zwei Burger-Menüs bestellt, Mittagessen. Und dann ruft der Typ an vom Lieferdienst
und meint, er kommt später, er verspätet sich irgendwie ein paar Minuten. Na ja, okay,
was soll ich machen? Ich warte halt. Dann kommt er an und sagt, ja, als Entschuldigung
hat er drei Burger-Menüs mitgebracht. Also ich habe die zwei auch schon nicht alleine
gegessen. Dann hat er drei Burger-Menüs. Ich musste dann letztens quasi eineinhalb,
oder sagen wir mal, eher zwei Burger-Menüs futtern. Wegen mir kann er gerne immer zu
spät kommen, wenn es eins umsonst gibt. Aber ich habe schon mal den Weg da geebnet. Lässt
du dich impfen? Wahrscheinlich schon, ja. Wahrscheinlich schon. Übrigens hier zu diesem
Impfthema, ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich dazu ein Video aufnehmen soll, aber das ist
ja so ein etwas... Ähm, Sekunde, warte mal. Hä? What the fuck? Wo sind wir am zweiten
Monitor? Ah, das ist Avira, null W. Das ist Avira. Avira ist der Meinung, ich bin super
ungeschützt, weil ich Avira nicht gekauft habe. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich den Scheiß
überhaupt noch installiert habe. Übrigens, also, ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich zu diesem
Impfthema ein Video aufnehmen soll. Und zwar, ähm, also, ich nehme dazu kein Video auf,
weil, wenn die Leute das im Titel schon sehen, da sind sie ja wieder getriggert. Aber was
ich eigentlich sagen wollte in den Videos, kann ich jetzt mal hier im Stream sagen, ich
wollte mich gar nicht über irgendwie, äh, impfen oder nicht impfen oder sowas auslassen.
Ich wollte mich darüber auslassen, warum ich denke, dass unsere Regierung oder generell
so viel in verantwortlichen Positionen selbst dran schuld sind, dass so viele Leute sagen,
sie wollen sich nicht impfen lassen. Oder teilweise zumindest. Zumindest mit dran schuld,
weil es wurde so viel Vertrauen verspielt, was, äh, Glaubwürdigkeit angeht, wegen dieser
ganzen Corona-Geschichte, dass ich jetzt die Leute sogar teilweise verstehen kann, wenn
sie komplett quasi, ähm, YOLO-mäßig oder so komplett ohne, ohne tieferen Sinn eigentlich
sagen, sie wollen sich nicht impfen lassen. Das kann ich nachvollziehen. Man darf nicht
vergessen, am Anfang wurde beispielsweise erzählt, ähm, Masken helfen nix. Dann kam
raus, ja doch, Masken helfen schon was, aber man hat es am Anfang gesagt, damit beispielsweise
kein Engpass bei Masken entsteht. Mag ein ehrenwertes Ziel sein, da sag ich gar nichts
dagegen. Aber es schafft auf jeden Fall nicht das Vertrauen, also es stärkt nicht das Vertrauen
in die Aussagen, die da getroffen werden. Dann wurde beispielsweise gesagt, man macht,
man macht diese, diese personenbezogenen Daten, also sprich, dort wo man ausfüllen muss,
ich hab irgendeinen Fussel am Mikro hängen, warte mal, dort wo man ausfüllen musste,
beim Friseur war im Übrigen schon, letzten, äh, letzten Donnerstag. Ähm, genau, und
dann gab es diese personenbezogenen Daten, wo man ausfüllen musste, wo man, oder sollte,
wo man war, und da haben die Leute ja mitgemacht, unter anderem auch, weil gesagt wurde, diese,
diese personenbezogenen Daten sind, also, wo man sich aufgehalten hat, wo man zu Mittag
essen war, äh, sind rein zweckgebunden, wenn für nichts anderes verwendet. Zwei Wochen
später oder so kam dann die bayerische Polizei und meinte, ach nö, nö, wir nehmen die auf,
wir greifen da auch drauf zu. So schaffst du halt kein Vertrauen in deine Aussagen. Und
das ist das eigentliche Problem, was ich denke, was bei vielen der Fall ist, warum sie sagen,
ich glaub keine mehr was, ich lass mich deswegen nicht impfen. Ich glaub gar nicht immer so
sehr, dass das daher kommt, dass die denken, dass sie irgendwie, äh, krank werden durch
die Impfung oder so. Einfach nur so, also ich glaub den Leuten aus Prinzip nix. Und
das haben die echt verschissen. Du kannst nicht, du kannst nicht einfach, und es gibt
ja noch viel mehr Beispiele, die jetzt nicht Corona bezogen sind, du kannst halt den Leuten
nicht einfach öfters mal Scheiße erzählen und dann, ähm, irgendwie hoffen die Leute,
warum die noch. Das, das klappt halt nicht, die waren halt nicht agil genug, ja. Also das
ist halt, das ist halt das Problem, was ich sehe dabei. Ich glaub vielen gehts gar nicht
darum, ob das Impfzeug irgendwie schädlich ist oder nicht. Die sagen so, ich glaub euch
aus Prinzip nix mehr. Ja, das ist normal bei Alstrike. Hab ich irgendwelche Subs übersehen?
Ja, das Stripes, Dankeschön, wie gesagt. Exquisite Hypersubscription, zwanzig Monate.
Ja, und da wollte ich eigentlich ein Video. Oh, hier Tribor, Dankeschön, 16 Monate Hypersubscription.
Die brauchen Agile, hab ich mir sagen lassen, spricht der sich ja aus. Agile. Ich hab übrigens,
wo wir gerade bei Agile und Poggers sind, ich hab mir nen, nen, nen, nen, nen Netzteil gekauft
von, bei Amazon, Top Charger. Top Charger. Keine Ahnung, wie man das ausspricht. Das
ist ein Netzteil. Top Charger, kommt aus Frankreich. Top Charger. Wie spricht man das aus? Ich
weiß nicht, irgendwie, ich dachte eigentlich ursprünglich, das ist ein China Netzteil,
weil das sind die, die, die chinesen Shops, die haben ja immer so Namen, das ist so bisschen
familiär oder bekannt klingen soll. Aber nein, das waren wirklich Franzosen. Was machst
du alles mit Kubernetes? Daheim gar nichts. Auf der Arbeit haben wir ein paar, mir fällt
schwer das Microservices zu nennen, ein paar umgewurstete, nicht so Microservices in Kubernetes,
die aber deswegen noch drei Spiele an Abhängigkeiten für einen Container brauchen, weil sie halt
nicht so micro sind. Macht sich cool, ja. Wie gesagt, lass ich. Bist du ein Docker-Fan?
Ich benutze Docker, ich weiß nicht, ob ich ein Docker-Fan bin. Ich find Docker gut und
so für den Desktop-Bereich eigentlich somit das Beste, was man, was man so nehmen kann.
Ich mein, es gibt noch ein paar Alternativen, man kann aktuell Potman nehmen, man könnte
auch das klassische Container-Format sein lassen und LXD nehmen, aber ich find Docker
an sich nicht schlecht, gerade durch das große Ökosystem, was es halt drumherum gibt. Ja,
nee, deswegen mach ich da, deswegen mach ich da kein Video zu, dass die, die Leute sind
wieder, ja, genau. Das ist, das ist so, das ist ein bisschen das Problem, weil ich hab
die Leute, die nur noch schwarz und weiß, ja. Es gibt ja auch noch ein bisschen was
dazwischen und es kann, es kann durchaus andere Gründe haben, außer dass man ein Verschwörungstheoretiker
ist, wenn man irgendwas nicht will, ja, oder wenn man was will, kann es auch andere Gründe
haben, dass man ein, wie sagen sie immer irgendwie, äh, gut, versiffter, Gutmensch, was auch
immer ist. Es gibt ja eigentlich, also in der Regel liegt die Wahrheit immer irgendwo
dazwischen und das ist das, was viele aktuell vergessen. Ja, denn die Corona-Videos, die
sind ja sogar abgeschaltet, die Comments, guck mal hier. Äh, ich hab doch irgendwo
ein Corona-Video offen. Der Aldi, der Aldi-Test, guck mal. Aldi-Test, wollte ich mal angucken.
Oh nee, ho, wo, die haben, oh, das hätt ich gar nicht gehört, die haben die Kommentare
an, selten, selten. Normalerweise sind die Comments immer aus. Ja, das ist doch nice.
Was ich halt dann auch wiederum nicht gut finde, ist, also wie gesagt, ich lass mich impfen,
aber was ich dann auch wiederum nicht so gut finde, ist, wenn man dann anfängt mit, ähm,
du musst jetzt quasi belegen, dass du geimpft bist, dass du manche Sachen machen darfst.
So sollte das nicht sein, ja. Also du solltest, du solltest quasi deine Freiheit ausüben
können, ohne dass du beweisen musst, dass du frei sein darfst. Das find ich nicht so
sinnvoll. Aber ich lass mich auf jeden Fall impfen, wenn's soweit ist. Übrigens, hier
habt ihr diese Diskussion um diese QR-Code-App mitgekriegt, Kontaktverfolgungs-App, die angeblich
Smudo mitprogrammiert hat. Vielleicht wart ihr auch so verwirrt wie ich, was Smudo damit
zu tun hat, aber der Typ hat früher angeblich wirklich auf dem C64 Spiele programmiert.
Wusste ich gar nicht. Gut, der wird wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich großartig was drin mit entwickelt
haben. Aber wisst ihr, was ich mich dabei frage, und das konnte mir noch keiner erklären.
Vielleicht, vielleicht kann das, oh Chat, ich muss euch übrigens gleich da noch was
anderes fragen. Es konnte mir noch keiner, nicht Sudo, Smudo. Sudo. Na wenn der Sudo
wäre das einfach, da müssten sich alle interessieren. So, also, was mir da noch keiner erklären
konnte, was ich nicht so genau verstanden habe, ist, warum kann man das nicht in die
Corona-App einbauen? Als Ernst, ich verstehs nicht, weil sowas lebt doch damit, dass das
viele Leute installiert haben. Wenn das nur 20 Leute installiert haben, bringt das doch
nix. So, und die Corona-App haben ja nun schon mittlerweile viele, viele installiert. Das
heißt man hätte eine relativ, relativ große Installationsbasis. Das heißt ich versteh
nicht, warum kann man das nicht in die Corona-App einbauen? Zumal, zumal man ja echt sagen
muss, GPS-Tracking, GPS-Tracking ist easy as fuck einzubauen. Das baue ich, das baue
ich in zwei Stunden ein. Jetzt ohne Scheiß, das ist nicht schwer. Ich hab das sogar schon
mal testweise gemacht, mit einer PWA, mit einer Web-App, aber GPS-Tracking ist wirklich
total einfach, auch Background-Tracking und das ist total einfach. Also, das könnte man
ohne Probleme in die Corona-App einbauen und ich weiß, dass das hier irgendwas Proprietäres
ist und die einen wollen was Offenes und sonst was, aber man könnte doch einfach zwei Fliegen
mit einer Klappe erschlagen. Man machts in die Corona-App ein, du kannst das an- oder
ausschalten, du musst ja eh der App GPS-Berechtigung geben oder nicht. Das kann ja in der App gar
nicht so. Also, die App fragt einfach, die sagt einfach Request Permission, GPS, Background
und entweder sagst du Ja oder Ne. Wenn du sagst Ne in dem Berechtigungsdialog, dann
macht die halt nach wie vor Bluetooth-Tracking und gut ist. Wenn du sagst Ja, dann kannst
dich tracken. So, und das zweite ist ja, was diese andere App irgendwie kann, ist du kannst
QR-Code scannen. Apple und Google erlauben keinen Zugriff auf GPS, wenn du das Covid-Trace
hast. Hä, wie? Ich kann von einer x-beliebigen Webseite auf GPS zugreifen, warum soll ich
das nicht aus der Corona-App machen können? Steh ich nicht. Ohne Zweifelsfall könnte man
sich da sicherlich als Regierung irgendwas bewegen. Das nächste ist die Sache mit dem
QR-Code. GPS-Tracking funktioniert halt nicht mehr so gut. Hä, na klar, du kannst dich
subscriben zum GPS-Tracking, du kannst die Location-Tracking-AP subscriben und dann wirst
du alle Major-Major-Location-Change oder glaube ich alle zwei Minuten mal kurz aufgeweckt.
Deine App und kann das machen. Ja, also das wären ja zwei Funktionen in einer App, die
miteinander nichts zu tun haben. Also man könnte da garantiert was machen. Zumindest
kannst du mir noch keiner schlüssig erklären. Es gibt nur so viele Vermutungen, wie so
ha, das geht nicht und sonst was. Ich hab die Vermutung, das liegt gar nicht an technischen
Gründen. Und das nächste ist diese QR-Code-Geschichte, das könnte man doch da auch easy einbauen.
Ne, das machen alle möglichen, was man so wie das Google Maps macht. Oder Apple Maps
oder Live 360 oder was auch immer. Nein, es gibt keine Gründe. Du kannst ja zustimmen
oder abschließen oder ablehnen. Also wie gesagt, das GPS-Tracking ist einfach einzubauen.
Das hab ich sogar selbst schon mal gemacht. Die Sache ist nur die. Das Problem ist nur
die GPS-Tracking alleine. Das bringt dir nichts. Was eine App des Bluetooth-Tracking benutzt,
was extra für Corona gebaut wird, kein Zugriff auf GPS-Anfragen, da kann man garantiert
irgendwas machen. Wie willst du denn sonst Location-Tracking machen ohne GPS? Und diese
ganze Sache mit den QR-Codes. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch hier drin steht. Es geht ja auch,
dass du QR-Codes scanst, wo du bist und so was. Das kann man doch auch alles einbauen.
Also ich verstehe nicht, warum die Leute sich noch eine zweite App installieren sollen,
was sie auch garantiert nicht machen werden und es wieder im Sande verlaufen wird. Warum
kann man nicht einfach sagen, wir haben eine offizielle App, die hat eine gewisse Reichweite,
wir bauen die einfach aus. Das leuchtet mir nicht ein. Und selbst wenn GPS nicht geht,
weil das irgendwelche Google-Limitierungen oder Apple-Limitierungen gibt, dann kann man
zumindest diese QR-Code-Geschichte einbauen. Ja, man könnte das auch noch einbauen, weil
wenn ich eine so eine, wo bin ich gewesen, App entwickeln würde, das würde ich über
drei verschiedene Sachen machen. Das würde ich einmal gucken, dass ich vielleicht Bluetooth
irgendwie gucke, was um mich drum herum ist, irgendwelche Beacons oder sonst wie. Dann
würde ich gucken, was für offene WLANs gibt es und sonstige Geschichten. Ich würde GPS
machen und ich würde Sachen zum Scannen und manuell Eintragen anbieten, wenn das nicht
stimmt, was da drin steht. Und mit GPS hast du den großen Vorteil, du kannst auch Reverse
Lookup machen, also sprich, wenn du gerade keine Ahnung hast, wo du bist, aber beispielsweise
du sitzt auf einer offenen Fläche, wo alle am Eis futtern sind, sagst du, ah ok, vielleicht
sollte ich besser mal das tracken lassen, dass ich hier jetzt irgendwie mit 20 Leuten
gesessen habe, irgendwie im Park Eis gegessen habe. So, dann machst du die App auf, also
so würde ich das machen, machst du die App auf, ok, hier gibt es keinen QR-Code zum Scannen,
ich drücke auf den Tracking Knopf, das Ding macht ein GPS, guckt GPS, macht ein Reverse
Geocoding, guckt wo ich bin auf der Karte, schlägt mir das nächstgelegene vor, was halt
eben irgendeine Geocode-AP ausspuckt, dann kriege ich ein vorausgefülltes Ding, so nach
dem Motto, das sind die Sachen, die wir jetzt übermitteln und dann kann ich noch korrigieren,
so nach dem Motto, ich bin nicht Hausnummer 31 oder Hausnummer 35, keine Ahnung, das schicke
ich ab. Das wäre das einfachste für die Leute, da kann man es nämlich auch manuell
erfassen. Also wie gesagt, das leuchtet mir nicht so genau ein. Moin Liko, ja, einfach
einfach, ganz ehrlich wegen mir können die Homeoffice Geschichten auch noch viel, mit
der Reverse so gibst du schon Meter Datenpreis, ja und, das mache ich doch bei 30 Milliarden
anderen Diensten auch, außerdem kann ich ja zustimmen oder ablehnen vorher, wenn ich
zustimme, muss ich mich danach nicht beschweren, dass ich Datenpreis gebe, weil ich habe zugestimmt.
Aber wenn ich nicht zustimme, muss ich mir keine Gedanken machen, dass das Ding Zugriff
drauf hat. Hast du das mit den Windows-Lizenzen mitbekommen? Ne, was denn? Erzähl. Habe ich
nicht mitgekommen? Ja, das dauert ewig. Das dauert ewig. Ja, ohne Center of Excellence
geht nichts. Hast du Empfehlung für Ein-U-Netzteile? Ne, aber weißt du, wie ich das bei meinem System
gemacht habe, ich habe ja hier in, wobei ich zeige es dir mal auf Twitter, ich habe ja hier,
habe ich das Bild, hier, hier unten in dieser 2 HE-Kiste, ne, da ist gar kein richtiges
Netzteil drinnen. Da ist so ein Netzteil drinnen. So was da in der Richtung. Liegt da einfach
im Gehäuse drin und hinten kommt der Stecker raus auf so einem freien Slot. Da ist gar
kein richtiges, richtiges Netzteil drinnen in der Kiste. Einfach das Ding ins Gehäuse
gelegt, den Kabel rausgemacht. Äh, ich habe mal eine Frage, bald steht Online-Prüfung
an über Moodle, okay. Warum habe ich eigentlich immer noch den Franzose eingeblendet? So,
äh, was? Moment, ich habe eine Frage, bald steht Online-Prüfung an, wir würden dir
gerne zusammen, also du möchtest bescheißen quasi auf gut Deutsch, seh ich das richtig,
ja? Äh, nein. Also wenn du das nicht über den Browser machst, kannst du das nicht
erkennen. Also die Webseite kann das nicht erkennen. Mir fällt zumindest nichts ein,
wie die das erkennen können und wenn du auf, ohne Scheiß, wenn du auf ganz Nummer sicher
gehen willst, dass man es definitiv niemals erkennen kann, ist Capture Card, zweiter Rechner,
dann erkennt niemand jemals irgendwas. Nummer sicher, Webcam auf Bildschirm richten, ja
das geht auch, aber das sieht scheiße aus. Twitch Mason, Prime Gaming, 10 Monate, Dankeschön
für den Sub. Aber ich würd's nicht machen, ja? Wie gesagt, seh ich auch so, ich würd's
nicht machen, wenn sie euch nämlich erwischen, ist die Prüfung wahrscheinlich instand ungültig
und du bist gefickt. Also ich würd's nicht machen, aber machbar ist es. Äh, Monshrewcx,
die E-Grills, die filmen ja auch sich und nicht ihren Bildschirm. Das ist ja wieder
was anderes. Falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, sag Bescheid. Spread the Peace, 17 Monate
Hypersubscription hier am Start, Massive. Wo hab ich meine Hypersubscription? Ja, das
ist natürlich auch ne Sache. Ähm, wenn das was ist, wo man wirklich Text eintragen muss,
ja und alle schreiben die gleichen Sätze rein, dann merkt man das. Ups, fuck, nein, ich hab
den Chat zu, aber ich hab den Chat ja zum Glück noch im anderen Bildschirm, lul. Ähm,
dann merkt man das, ja, aber halt nicht daran, dass ich den Bildschirm geschert hab, sondern
weil man's anderweitig merkt. Äh, ich hab zu weit hochgescrollt. Nee, ich hab nix
übersehen, oder? Kann das sein? Muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Abos übersehen
hab. Übrigens, Microsoft hat das gleiche Problem bei ihren Zertifikaten und die haben
da ganz, ganz strikte Regelungen. Also, du wirst beobachtet, genau, du wirst beobachtet,
während du die Prüfung machst, du musst vorher mit der Kamera deinen Raum zeigen,
du musst die Tür geschlossen haben, also du darfst nicht reden während der Prüfung,
es darf nichts, nichts sichtbar sein, außer du und deine Tastatur auf der, auf der Kamera
während der gesamten Prüfung. Also, die sind da bei ihren Zertifikaten wirklich hardcore
drauf. Ist jetzt kein Witz, das machen die wirklich. Natürlich, natürlich gibt's, gibt's
Sachen, wo das nicht so ist, aber wie gesagt, Microsoft ist da sehr pingelig bei beispielsweise
ihren Azure Zertifikaten und sowas. Ja. So, gucken wir mal was. Mit was, mit was, mit
was fangen wir denn an? Mit was, mit was, mit was fangen wir an? Okay, wir gucken uns,
wir gucken uns jetzt mal, wir gucken uns mal das Level Cap Video an, weil ich weiß, dass
ich das zwei Minuten gucken werde und danach ausschalte und mir sage wieder, warum hast
du das geguckt? Der Typ erzählt eh 0815 Zeug, die ist, also in letzter Zeit, die ist nicht
wert, ein Video drüber zu machen, aber macht trotzdem Videos drüber. So, mal gucken, ob
wir wieder jebaited werden. Ein bold move haben sie gemacht. Was könnt, okay, okay, was
könnte ein mutiger Schritt von EA sein, was Battlefield angeht? Auf die Spieler hören
vielleicht, aber das macht man wahrscheinlich nicht. Stripes 07, ja gut, du kannst da aber
auch trotzdem so ein Netzteil reinstecken, wie ich gezeigt habe, und das Kabel raus
mal hinten. Okay, okay, wenn das EA selbst sagt, dann ist es wahrscheinlich alles andere
als bold, weil EA nur das macht, was stonkisch ist. Fällt mir im Prinzip ganz gut, stonkisch
passt sehr gut das Wort. Also, ich mein, wenn das ernsthaft Ende des Jahres rauskommen
sollte, ein paar spielbare Alphas sollten sie durchaus schon haben, kein komplettes Produkt,
aber zumindest teilweise spielbare Sachen. Okay, bla bla bla, bla bla bla, who cares,
ist mir sowas von scheiße egal, ob sie den for speed. Was, was, aber warum? Aber ich
mein, jetzt mal ernsthaft, viel hilft nicht immer viel, ja. Also sprich, die können ja
schlecht 5000 Leute an Battlefield setzen und meinen, das wird dann ein besseres Game.
Oh nee.
Out of Dice LA the reveal trailer for battlefield sixes already in production ea says it's shaping up to be a truly
Wundert mich nicht dass sie das sagen
Und es wäre auch merkwürdig wenn da released also wenn der ankündigungs trailer noch nicht in production wäre weil
Wenn das wirklich ende des jahres rauskommt da müssen wir langsam mal was ankündigen
Oder teesen
Alter was ist das für jude im gewesen gerade der reveal trailer so i'll believe it when i see it one thing that should give
Players hope for battlefield sixes that ea gave dice an extra year to work on it rumors and estimates put battlefield fives total development
Time around 18 months which is an absurdly short amount of time for a game that big
Battlefield six getting at least two years of active development can only mean good things just don't base your expectations on what ea or anyone else says
Ja korrekt aber deswegen das ist so geil das ist so geil was fast in der krieg was für eine geile aussage sagt im motto
Gebt nix drauf was ea sagt aber ich mache erst mal ein video über alles das was ea gesagt hat
Wobei auf der anderen seite kann ich das ja nicht mal verwerflich finden das würde ich wahrscheinlich auch machen wenn es irgendwas interessant das wäre was sie gesagt
Händen für huge success just as much as it is an opportunity to crash and burn i think we all hope that battlefield six will be amazing
But it's unrealistic to say that it definitely will be based on the little information that we have
Es ist es ist absolut unrealistisch überhaupt was zu dem game zu sagen man hatte noch nicht mal in game
Irgendwie nicht mal in game leak bilder oder so gesehen gar nix
Despite rolling out some intense competition for nvidia's 30-series
Da können wir uns machen wir gleich weiter kommen wir gucken uns jetzt
Battlefield battlefield vier top plays an wenn wir gerade schon mal battlefield waren fangen wir damit mal an
Auch immer logitech sehr laut jetzt
Alter was hat der typ für einen bass setting
Aber
Der hört nur noch basst der typ oder
Gatschi bass ich lasse es absichtlich leiser
Weil ich laber ja immer drüber wo ist ein hetzer sehr laut ich habe mit hetzer nichts zu tun gehabt
also mit der marketing abteilung
Ja das ist immer so die gegner schiessen nicht zurück
Da sind bestimmt 20 sniper die nicht wissen was sie machen sollen deswegen auf dem haus kämpfe und unterscheid
Das ist immer so die gegner schiessen nicht zurück
Ich frage mich nur gerade was machen die da eigentlich alle auf dem dach
Da sind bestimmt 20 sniper die nicht wissen was sie machen sollen deswegen auf dem haus kämpfe und unterscheid
Was machen die dudes da oben alle
Corona
Und
Du könnt wolltest doch jetzt eine affiliate machen also in den affiliate programm mache ich nicht
Sack gaming excellent wenn schon wenn schon muss ich mit denen mich mal direkt da kurz schließen was man das erlaubt mäßig machen könnte
Ich kann wie gesagt auf youtube auf auf twitch könnte man das ja alles gut platzieren das wäre auch ein server anbieter wo ich
Selbst mal ein graben habe ich weiß dass die was taugen
Da muss ich mit ihnen mal in in in touch gehen ja aber habe ich gerade keinen bock mich drum zu kümmern
Schottkampf
Auf
Ich dachte der messer den jetzt aber das wäre eine blöde idee gewesen mit drei spieler einen gegner drum herum
Gegner ihr dürft auch zurückballern ja das ist erlaubt
War das in battlefield 4 nicht so dass ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern im battlefield 3 hat so pression dafür
Gesorgt dass du nichts mehr triff im battlefield 4 was so pression noch optisch außer bei lmgs oder oder auch bei lmgs nur noch optisch
Ich
Christopher 2jj is next another mg4 backrage on metro
backrage
awesome to see a nicer backrage
They don't have a chance, they're all stuck there reloaded trying to work out what to do eventually he does get stopped with what seems like
Second could be sent in using the uts-15. Das ist ein ding das ding habe ich noch nie gespielt
15 rounds does mean that you can get into a bit of a flow when you're das habe ich noch nie gespielt das ding
Top marks for that you see many players on the top plays or at least players who send clips in refusing to revive
I think that is a big bad mark against your day
Man schickst du deine clips ein wenn ich nicht so faul wäre hätte ich schon längst eingeschickt
Oh leute das ist auf der falschen seite so hier ist besser
Ich muss sie im hintergrund, aber echt nicer klipp
Krasse bashed werden sie
By the way, ich habe das salami emote konserviert fällt euch das auf das ist überall gelöscht mittlerweile ich hab's noch
Twitch Twitch
First only
Salami nicht fast last twitch last salami
Warum ist die weg weil die gesagt haben sie wollen keine anstößtigen emote haben
Sehr laut
Also logitech ist auch was wo ich mich sponsoren lassen würde
Das ist auch ich ich benutze schon lange logitech sachen findet ihr eigentlich auch ganz gut
einzige
Wo ich so ein bisschen für geflammt habe ist meine letzte tastatur
wo die
Wo die controltaste einfach abgebrochen ist
Ja und wäre als sponsor würde ich auch so fortnehmen
Wenn du findest logitech hat es ja abgenommen okay, warum
Wenn du findest logitech hat es ja abgenommen
Okay, warum
Was
Also ich muss sagen mit der letzten tastatur war ich auch nicht zufrieden wo die controltaste abgebrochen ist aber immer noch besser als die kursar
Tastatur mit doppelten tasten anschlägen wenigstens ging die ging und geht die logitech tastatur noch
außer die controltaste
Ja nun plot muss sein
Nächste ist die wabbs kann du dich erinnern was das ist wobei meine lieblingstaste
Wisst ihr was meine lieblingstastatur ist ernsthaft also
nicht für daheim nicht für spiele und macros aber meine lieblingstastatur so generell zum benutzen
Die da
Aber mit num block die da
Besser
Ich zum spielen weiß ich nicht ob ich der anderen vorziehen würde
Und man kann auch das hat auch keine macros software dabei was auch ein bisschen doof ist
Ich will so die paar kleinigkeiten mache ich gerne mit macros zum beispiel desktop switchen und so was
Aber rein zum tippen und zum arbeiten ist das mein absolut lieblingstastatur übrigens die meine ich nicht ich habe eine mit komplett
hohem enter
nicht so ein crap da
Mit num block mit num block und mit enter so eine da mit num block und enter
nicht so was ist für ein crap
sowas da genau
das da beste
und num block
Danny lull 20 monate massive subscriptions hier wieder
Danke für die subs
Also wie gesagt das meine lieblingstastatur
So sind wir stehen geblieben
Wie gesagt jetzt wo die so viele leute da sind ich hab es halt ein paar tagen übelst kopfe ich weiß nicht wie lange ich am start bin heute
Aber aktuell aktuell geht's
My favorite weapon in the game und der chat ist ich sicher es liegt an 5g und in der 44 magnum
in Closed Quarters
wave of enemy players
Totra of souls ist nächstes hot sure of souls wisst ihr was das ist ein name
Den kann nur jemand haben der
Der älter ist das ist so ein typischer das ist so ein typischer emo name gibt es ja heute nicht mehr
Wurdest du geimpft nicht bin ich dick genug ich darf noch nicht ich darf jetzt erst ich darf jetzt erst dann wenn alle anderen auch dürfen
Ab einem bmi von 40 da darf man ja auch vorher
Genau das so typische emo name die sind die gibt es ja auch nicht mehr keine emos mehr guck mal in die
Guck mal warum akt okay aktuell ähnlich aber guck mal es gibt kaum noch welche mehr kaum noch mehr mit irgendwelchen dunklen dingern an
Geschminkt und augenringen und alles es gibt und diese komischen rucksäcke mit anhänger und sowas
Es gibt keine emos mehr wo sind die alle hin aber der war bestimmt mal einer torture of souls der name ist so emo mäßig
Meinst du corona ist daran schon ne die waren vorher auch schon weg
Ich hab ja früher auch so ein bisschen so emo musik gehört sowas in der richtung so aber eher Richtung metal sachen
Das war einfach das war einfach andere andere zeit
Das hat aber nicht so gut funktioniert
Nice nice headshot scoped warum haben die ganzen schneiber dudes eigentlich in battle field laser ist das weniger bullet drop oder oder oder was mein man
Kann mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern wie das ist bei battlefield 4
Oder sieht man es einfach besser
Besseren
Schraube aus der hüfte eigentlich die Autoren sind mir immer komm ich glaube mal im
hereb
N contribuent
A.C.E 23, Ding war POG, oder ACE, ich weiß nicht, Leute wie spricht man das, ACE?
A.C.E oder ACE? Ich denke mal, das ist ne Abkürzung.
Arschl? Ja, das wird's sein.
A.C.E, das ist so ein Multivitaminsaft. Genau, Killrock, genau das wollte ich auch
gerade sagen. Das ist so ein Multivitaminsaft. Ja, der Leko, das hat der Harter Sebaru mal
ausprobieren, fand's ganz toll. Ich mag eher mein selbst konfiguriertes E3.
Das ist ne F dazwischen. Das sind auch wieder Gegner, die nicht
zurückschießen, ne? Alter, was hat der für ne Sense, der Dude?
What the fuck? Der bewegt die Maus und... Oh, was ist das?
Wusstet ihr, dass man das im Vollbild einblenden kann?
Das ist mir neu. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das geht, wie blenden
kann man das jetzt ein? Ah, da kann man ziehen!
Das ist mir neu, das hab ich gerade aus Versehen rausbekommen beim Wildmaus rumwackeln.
Das mit Scrollen kenn ich. Und Vorwärts- und Rückwärtsspulen kenn ich
mittlerweile auch. Also, frameweise.
Pogu. Wie, warum ist Pogu weg? Aber jetzt haben wir in Pognitor haben wir
jetzt. Was?
Was, was heißt hier less skillful? Das ist ja wohl offensichtlich, das offen,
also total offensichtlich absolutes Highskill-Gameplay, C4 droppen und Knopf drücken.
Vor allem, wie sie nicht rauslaufen. Man kann auch mit Wim-Bindings Videos pausieren
und skippen. Wie soll man das machen?
Also H und L oder was? Ach, nicht wirklich.
Nee. Nur bei mir geht J und L, K geht bei mir nicht.
H macht Pause, aber das sind nur halbe Wim-Bindings. Links und rechts in Wim, also J, K ist doch
hoch und runter und H, L ist links und rechts. Das ist fake Wim-Bindings.
Alter, wie die da weiterhin reinrennen. Ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich sowas sehe.
Ist es nicht auffällig, wenn schon 20 Leute vor dir im C4 in die Luft gesprengt wurden,
muss man da auch noch reinrennen? Forever Nexus gibt es schon.
Ist das Konsole? Ist das Konsole?
Das Konsole, ja, okay dann. Dann wundert mich ja nichts mehr.
Wer Empfehlung für Steckdose, die Strom messen kann? Ja, ich habe ein paar da, aber ich glaube,
die kann man nicht mehr flashen und die gibt es auch nur noch, also die gibt es flashbar
oder nicht mehr. Oder ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, ob man die noch flashen kann. Ich
glaube eher nicht. Also ich habe aktuell an meinem 3D-Drucker
gerade den hier angeschlossen. Das ist den, den wir übrigens geflasht haben
letzten zusammen im Stream, wo ihr gedacht habt, ich prick mein Gerät.
Den da, 16. Die da. Ich weiß nicht, ob man die noch flashen
kann. Keine Ahnung. Muss man gucken, dass die ein bisschen billiger,
wobei ein 4er Pack für 36€ ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Was kann man gegen Spulenfiepen machen, außer Strom ausschalten?
Da gibt es die große Geheimwaffe aller Bastler. Heißkleber.
Einfach in Heißkleber tränken und dann spulenfiept es nicht mehr.
Aber es geht, also es funktioniert wirklich. Das Spulenfiepen kommt ja daher, moin Chainlord,
das kommt ja daher, dass das vibriert und wenn du das in Heißkleber heißkleberst, dann
wird das nichts mehr haben. Ob das jetzt so gut ist für Wärmeableitungen
und so sei mal dahingestellt. Wie gesagt, also die habe ich gerade, aber
ich habe mir die Dinger ja noch letztes Jahr gekauft.
Das ist übrigens die, ich glaube die haben wir auch mal im Stream geflasht.
Zumindest die können das in der richtigen Variante, die können Strom messen.
Ich versuche es euch mal zu zeigen für einen 3D Drucker.
Ich glaube 100, was 128? Ich glaube 108 war es oder?
Guck mal, da sieht man es. Das ist die, die ich gerade am 3D Drucker
dran habe. Und wenn ich den 3D Drucker anschalte, ich
schalte jetzt mal den 3D Drucker an. Ich weiß nicht, ob es im Hintergrund hört,
oder ob es jetzt piepst. Habt ihr?
Hört man nicht, oder? Das ist zu leise, das ist ja auch hinter
der Tür. Doch, hat man gehört?
Okay, nice. Das ist bei mir im Serverraum hinter der Tür
gewesen. Also jetzt ist, jetzt ist gerade dieser 3D
Drucker hier, hat sich eingeschaltet, ja. Und der verbraucht gerade 10 Watt.
Was jetzt nicht so viel ist, weil der ist ja auch noch nicht warm.
Na ja, da würde ich jetzt nicht so viel drauf geben, was hier steht, ja.
So, und, also die können das, wie du siehst, ja.
Ich kann ja mal was drucken, ob 105 ist man, wobei, ich kann einfach sagen, Okto.
Exquisite Passport, kommt keiner drauf. Habe ich nämlich erst letztens neu installiert
in OktoPie. Wir gucken mal, wie der Energie, Alter.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Leute. Kurz Musik anmachen.
Exzellent. So, ich kann mich mal verbinden zu meinem
3D Drucker. Und wir drucken jetzt mal, wir drucken jetzt
mal irgendwas. Ich könnte, ich könnte aber was wirklich
sinnvolles drucken, Leute, fällt mir gerade auf.
Ich könnte, ich könnte die Unterseite hierfür nochmal drucken.
Moment, wo habe ich denn das, wo habe ich denn das hier überhaupt her?
Irgendwo Thingiverse, aber ich weiß nicht mal, wie es heißt.
Ah, ich weiß nicht mal, wie es heißt bei Thingiverse.
Ok, dann druck ich das jetzt einfach mal. So, das druckt nur 23 Minuten oder so.
Wobei Leute, wisst ihr was, ich lasse einfach, ich lasse einfach nur mal aufwärmen.
Ich lasse einfach nur mal aufwärmen. So, drucken.
Und jetzt, und jetzt wärmt der. Und jetzt gucken wir uns mal den Stromverbrauch
an. Monka Smoke, jetzt geht's rauf.
Der Kran wird halt heiß, ne? Und das ist aktuell nur das Bett.
Wartet mal ab, wartet mal ab, bis der, bis der die Düse aufheizt auf, auf 200 Grad.
Aktuell heizt der nur das Bett und braucht 223 Schwarte 3D Drucker.
Was für ein Drucker hast du, das ist ein Anycubic E3 Mega S.
So, wir warten jetzt nochmal eine Minute, dann geht nämlich die eigentliche Heizung
an und dann muss ich, dann breche ich ab, weil ich will den Kram gar nicht nochmal drucken.
Was für eine, eine USB hast du, gar keine. Ich hab hier unten zwar eine drinne, aber
die ist nicht angeschlossen, weil die Batterie kaputt ist.
Und ich will die nicht, ich will die nicht mehr anschließen, die hab ich jetzt rein
als Beschwerung von dem Rack drinne, ich will die auch gar nicht mehr anschließen, weil
es fällt alles aus, wenn die Batterie ausfällt, was hängen geblieben ist, das ist eine Offline
USB, also es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Also solange Strom da ist und die Batterie
abkackt, soll's gefällig weiter funktionieren. So, jetzt, jetzt bin ich mal geschnitten,
ich bin gespannt, also jetzt ist das Bett gleich aufgeheizt, jetzt mal gucken, wieviel
er dann braucht. Jetzt nehmen wir mal 212, 212 Watt, ist da gerade, guck mal, der kann
sogar Energieverbrauch zählen, eigentlich richtig nice. Huge, sozusagen, huge, huge.
So, auf, jetzt hochfahren, die Nozzle warm machen, nee, nicht die, die, das Heater Ding
warm machen und dann mal gucken, wieviel er verbraucht, bin ich mal gespannt, hab ich
selbst noch nicht geguckt. Übrigens, ähm, auch so ne Sache, äh, ich kann jetzt hier
den 3D-Drucker einfach ausschalten, ne, Extruder, genau, aber es würde ich nicht empfehlen,
ich würde sagen, nachdem man den Druck kanzelt, sollte man immer noch mal kurz warten, dass,
dass der Lüfter, wenn ich das einfach ausschalte, dann dreht sich der Lüfter nicht mehr und
es ist heiß. Also besser man schaltet aus und wartet 5 Minuten, bevor man komplett Strom
ausmacht. So, auf, fang an zu heizen, 3D-Drucker, let's go. Hattest du nicht mal mit über
Valetudo Flash, ähm, also ich hab kein Video drüber gemacht, wir haben Video drüber geguckt
und eben, ja, ich weiß, dass bei den neuen Roborocks es nicht mehr geht, aber ich hab
Glück und mein Staubsauger-Roboter ließ sich noch flashen. Sogar ich hab letztens abgecreated
auf die neuste Version. Der kann dann so Dinger machen jetzt, wie, äh, verschiedene, verschiedene
Stockwerke und alles mögliche und, ja, weil's immer wieder Leute hören, ich hab mein Staubsauger-Roboter,
ich hab meinen Staubsauger geflashed und mein Staubsauger hat jetzt ein Webinterface. Äh,
S5 beziehungsweise S50, das ist der gleiche. Okay, jetzt wird geheizt, Leute. Wie? Der
braucht weniger. Weniger als mit dem Heiz. Ah, ggbaited, ggbaited. Hä, der wechselt sich
voll ab, guck mal. Na gut, was soll, wie dem auch sagen, ich brech den Druck jetzt ab.
Yes, cancel. Ich brech das jetzt ab, weil ich will, ich will das ja überhaupt nicht
drucken. Der Heiz-Champ, genau. Ich will das ja überhaupt nicht drucken. So, ich warte
jetzt kurz, bis es runtergeht. Jetzt gucken wir weiter und, äh, dann mach ich das wieder
ab. Hallo, ich hab gecancelt, du solltest jetzt eigentlich nicht weiter hochgehen. Wie
wär's mit ausgehen? Nicht, dass der jetzt noch anfängt zu drucken. Stopp. Stopp. Äh,
die Webcam hab ich abgemacht, ich kann grad nicht gucken. Stopp, stell so, Dankeschön
für den Sub, 13 Monate Hyper-Subscription hier. Stopp. Der will nicht. Ah, jetzt, äh,
das kann nicht sein. Das kann nicht sein. Das glaub ich nicht. Okay, jetzt hat er abgebrochen.
Jetzt hat er abgebrochen. Das, das war ein wenig unrealistisch gerade hier. Ach ne, das
ist Target Temperature, das ist Target Temperature. Das ist die Target Temperature, das ist die
aktuelle Temperatur. Captain Sieg, 10 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub. Exquisite Subscription.
Okay, genug 3D, so, jetzt ist es kalt genug. Jetzt kann ich hier hingehen und sagen Bam,
3D Drucker off. Bam. Äh. Ah, hat ein bisschen gedauert, okay, was auch immer. Nice, so,
jetzt ist er wieder aus. Sehr schön. Okay, guck mal weiter. Wir sind glaub ich auch noch
bei Battlefield. Äh, in Rechner, wo die Grafikkarte fett ballert, läuft drüber. Jaja, klar.
Aber, äh, ich find 250 schon, äh, nicht ohne, ja. Also es ist auf definitiv genug, wenn
man nicht zuguckt und was schief geht, dass es Haus abfackeln kann. Und, na gut, ist es
nichts gegen den Heizlüfter mit 2000 Watt oder gegen den Herd mit, frag mich nicht wie
viel. Bam, bababam, da werden sie durch den Smoke gebashed. Richtig Monka-Smoke. Okay,
das übliche, das übliche, die Gegner sehen wieder nix. Coole Setup, ja, du musst, du
musst dir das, du müsstest das jetzt mal sehen, jetzt ist es mittlerweile noch besser.
Jetzt hab ich nämlich mittlerweile den Kram ordentlich verkabelt und auch das ganze 3D
Druckerzeug dahingehängt schon. Sag mal, spielen die, wird in Battlefield 4 nur noch
locker gespielt. Ich hab doch ein Säuferraum-Video gemacht vor 5 Tagen oder so. Noch eins, da
muss es erst wirklich komplett fertig sein. Ich hab das Gefühl, der AEK Reload ist in
Battlefield viel schneller als in Battlefield 3. Kann das sein? Oder, oder täuscht das?
Weil der AEK Reload in Battlefield 3 kommt mir so ultra-extrem-Resident-Sleeper langsam
vor. LeChuck, danke schön, 15 Monate Subscription. Massive. Oh, das Gametrain ist am Start. Ah,
wer hat das gedacht? Nochmal ein locker Clip. Boah, hier, Maus-Cam in Battlefield 4. Der
will es aber professionell jetzt echt wissen. Oh, was ist jetzt los? Huge, was nun passiert.
Liko hat 5 Abos gegiftet. Sehe ich das richtig? Danke schön für die ganzen Subs. Huge Subscriptions.
Wir hatten was gekriegt, zeig mal her. Bye-Bane, gelber Nasenaffe, gigantic, Qubes unter Informatiker
underscore. Excellent, excellent. Huge Subscriptions. Gametrain hatte ich gescampt, ja, wenigstens
hab ich von dem Gametrain was. Besser als Leute lassen sich in der WhatsApp-Gruppe
scammen, da hab ich nix von. Chat, ich muss euch nach dem Battlefield-Video was wichtiges
fragen. Und nicht, ob ihr in meine WhatsApp-Gruppe kommt. Letztens wurde mir ein Video vom Klassiker
schlechthin empfohlen, ja. Ich weiß nicht, warum mir KLS-Videos empfohlen werden, keine
Ahnung. Der Kell ist komplett nur noch Meme mittlerweile, oder? Er selbst nimmt es ja noch
übelst ernst, aber die Kommentare haben ja absolut nichts mehr damit zu tun. Früher
wurde das ja immer voll gefeiert, ja. Die Leute so nach dem Motto, oh ja, geil, da zeigt
uns wie das krasse Business geht. Und heute machen die sich alle lustig in den Kommentaren
drüber. Und die Videos, die Videos sind so auf dem Niveau von Teleshopping früher. Von
irgendwelchen Teleshopping-Verkaufsveranstaltungen. Verdient er wirklich damit Geld? Ich mein,
muss er ja, sonst, okay, vielleicht pfeift er auch auf dem letzten Loch, keine Ahnung,
ich hab schon lange kein krasser Lifestyle am Strand mehr gesehen. Aber das wiegt wie
billiges Teleshopping.
Alter, komm, hier, wenigstens mal einen Battlefield-Spieler mit fast CS-Sense. Ja, wenigstens mal, wenigstens
mal das gesamte Mousepad für eine halbe Drehung, so muss das sein. Kann nicht sein, dass man
aus dem Handgelenk aimt. Warum hat er die Maus so weit hinten? Naja, dass sein Arm aufliegt,
sonst, entweder bräuchte er eine Armauflage, die dann so kurz ist, bzw. so eng, oder er
müsste die ganze Zeit sein Arm in der Luft halten, also das kann ich schon verstehen.
Ich bin ja kein Arm-Amer, ich mach so ein Zwischending. Ich Handgelenk-Ame und wenn
es gar so schnell, gewisse Distanz und schnell ist, dann noch ein bisschen mit dem Arm, aber
ich bin lazy, ich Handgelenk-Ame lieber. Deswegen bin ich auch so faul, was Bewegung angeht
und versuch schon immer in die richtige Richtung zu gucken. Also die richtig guten Spieler
siehst du in allen Games, die predicten wo die Gegner sind, aber gucken trotzdem permanent
rum was Sache ist. Und ich verlasse mich darauf, dass ich richtig predikte und wenn ich falsch
predictet habe wo Gegner sind, bin ich halt am Arsch. Ich bin halt zu faul für. Es heißt
hier der
Exzellent, geht nur ein, geht nur drei Minuten. Ich will mir den Aldi schnell testen.
Ich kauf, dann kauf ich mir, ich kauf mir morgen den Aldi Schnelltest und dann mach ich dann
Max Corona ja oder nein revealed
Ach die sind ausverkauft, okay
Erzhaft
Hast du die I reaps doku schon gesehen nee
War I reaps nicht nicht nicht dieses das mädchen was gesagt hat als die sniper clips gemacht hat dies gar kein mädchen war
zu mw2 zeiten
oder bring ich das jetzt durcheinander
Ich will eigentlich nur sehen wie er den test macht wie macht man den test denn
Die hatten die hatten auch garantiert kein ard oder sonst was bonus dass sie noch kein wdr bonus dass sie noch was bekommen haben garantiert nicht
Nein, gibt es online zu kaufen ich macht ich mache schnelltests in den preisschamp
Schnellte oder oder
Oder testchamp
Okay, wie testet man sich damit
Da doch so viel 11 stück
Ich dachte haben sie nicht letztens erzählt
In zwei tagen startet der verkauf und sie haben tausende und jeder kann sich einen kaufen okay
wie wie so immer ist
Der unterschied zwischen was gesagt wird in realität ein bisschen größer
Okay, wie testet man sich
Zeig her wie testet man sich steckt man sich das in der hals steckt man sich das in die nass
Muss man sich da irgendwie blut tropfen tropfen
Ja ja labern ich will einfach ich will wissen wie man das benutzt
Test
So funktionieren die coronatest so geil drei minuten beitrag zwei minuten schwach sind und wie funktioniert der test jetzt aha hier
Man soll sich das so weit in die nass schieben dass man oben rauskommt ja ist klar
Ne ne ne das meint es ist eklig das mache ich nicht
Du sollst du das durch die nass schieben bist du bist du quasi hinter der nass bist ich geht das ist ja unangenehm
Vermischen
Ja auf macht da muss ich das selbst nicht machen
Das ergebnis ich bin ich interessiert ja ja rein damit rein damit
Also es ist ein bisschen
Danach das stäbchen 30 sekunden in die testflüssigkeit tunken kurz schütteln und drei tropfen auf eine testkassette
Das ist wieder hier exquisite test da muss wieder pfeiffer sein dass du das machen kannst und
Und lass mich raten er hat kein corona
Ich meine guck mal
Die haben zwei minuten dreißig beitrag gemacht der eigentlich nur 45 sekunden lang sein müsste
Crap
Hast du das neue bänke ja habe ich schon gesehen ist das lustig
Es ist lustig dieses drei minuten wo er wo er geht hab dinge alle ablehnt ja
So was habe ich hier übersehen
Was machen die chinesen schon wieder
Die die die chinesen in china
Ich habe zwölf jahre auf dem ist das ist eine fucking stunde lang das video das gucke ich jetzt net
Und wenn die chinesen in china chemie machen oje dann hat es ja gar nicht mehr auf
Haben sie was übersehen
Das können wir nicht gucken das geht eine stunde das video das ist zu lang
Ja und was kommt jetzt in dem video raus ist es jetzt ein mädchen oder nicht
Das ist jetzt interessiert war das war das mw2 sniper grill oder nicht
Tec tec fails they want you to forget ok das können wir gucken
Gucken wir gucken also wenn wenn das serious mag sagt dass das gutes video ist dann können wir das noch mal mit aufnehmen
Ok habe ich was übersehen
Die
Tele shopping ja kam millennia
Ja
Hast du das gemerkt ja na gut das kämmt ja auch aktuell aktuell keine leute mehr hoffe ich mal zumindest
Mein vater hat die leute gescampt früher aber ich glaube ich glaube gerade es kämmt also nicht mehr
Ist schon ganze weile her wo der leute gescampt hat aber da war ein profi scammer
Der hatte das drauf okay ich habe nichts vergessen
Ich habe immer ein peak tutorial das war noch zeiten
Wenn ihr die habe ich schon gesehen
Liko die die dinger die sind die sind immer nicht schlecht die diese
habe ich sogar glaube ich sogar noch eins auf davon
Okay, also wir gucken jetzt wir gucken jetzt
Die dunkle wahrheit hinter punkt tv domains und das gucken wir während wir auf twitch punkt tv sind
Ich kann euch aber wahrscheinlich schon sagen was die dunkle wahrheit ist ohne das video gesehen zu haben
Punkt tv ist glaube ich eine domain von irgend so einem mini land
Ich weiß aber nicht ob das wirklich die dunkle wahrheit ist ehrlich gesagt
Also ich weiß dass tv ist keine neue domain wie
Punkt gay oder so was es jetzt gibt gibt es wirklich
Es ist von irgendeinem land tu war ich habe keine tu war lu was zum
valo
Island country polynesien so blöd
wo zum teufel ist das
Moment
Das ist so klein dass es auf google maps und nicht mal zu sehen ist die haben bestimmt nicht ein corona fall wetten
Wo ist es da da ist es
Also google map meint
Da
Guck mal das sind heuser vier heuser das sieht ein bisschen aus wie wake island ja
krass wieviel wieviel wieviel einwohner hat das
das ist ehemalige nicht kokona ehemalige was gibt es irgendein schönes britisches
emote teatime genau das teatime emote ne 3 hat eus in die australia
oder oder oder oder oder uk leute mit einem komischen dialect geht beides ok einwohner
11.000 au das werden weniger leute fast 1000 leute weniger ok wir gucken uns jetzt das mit an
funa falla das ist bestimmt nice die haben bestimmt kein korona
exzellent
moment hier haben verschiedenste endungen diese endungen nennt man top level domains kurz
best top level domain es gibt aber auch hippe domains wie punkt tv oder punkt li oder für
die coolen supercoder unter euch dort o domains kosten geld wenn ich zum beispiel ich habe mich
in den jahren vertan ok da ist es um 1000 gestiegen von 2017 2019 tv registrieren will bezahle ich
circa 25 euro pro jahr plus erweige extra wie viel sag sag auch registrieren will bezahle
ich circa 25 kann kann durchaus sein ja gucken wir mal meinem billig billig domain registrar
den ich nicht empfehlen werde weil sie keine dns ap haben aber wo ich ein paar domains hab also
check wait punkt tv 26 dollar lustigerweise sind die domains und kommen domains mittlerweile voll
billig ja guck mal punkt komm ist übelst billig geworden denkt man gar nicht 20 euro pro jahr plus
erweige extra kosten und leider steckt hinter dem geschäft mit einigen dieser endungen eine dunkle
wahrheit ganz wenige mächtige gewinner auf der einen seite der erde und hilflose verlierer auf
der anderen heute geht es um die chaotischen anfänge des internets skrupellose geschäftsmänner
ahnungslose inselstaaten und digitales jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen viele domains beziehen
sich auf bestimmte länder punkte e für deutschland zum beispiel das geht zurück auf den amerikanischen
wissenschaftler john poste der university of californien das punkt kokona hat er auf der
basis dieses iso ist festgelegt das internet war damals noch winzig ein kleines netzwerk
das von einigen wenigen menschen quasi zusammen getüftelt wurde dementsprechend hat postal die
administration für verschiedene länder domains anfangs einfach an sich und ein paar kollegen
verteilt er selbst hat lange zeit dort us gemanagt dort uk ging zum beispiel an einen britischen
professor kumpel aber das internet wurde immer größer und beliebter 1994 führte postal deshalb
ein paar regeln für die vergabe der länder domains ein administratoren sollten zumindest in
irgendeiner art und weise etwas mit dem jeweiligen land zu tun haben was und mindestens eine
seit wann was sind denn das für regeln dass derjenige der sich um was kümmert ahnung haben muss das ist
überhaupt nicht agil und nicht eitel konform verwaltung musste tatsächlich dort leben du
musst einfach nur regelmäßige daily stand ups machen und und tribe meetings dann musst du
da keine ahnung für haben sollte das internet mit hilfe der nationalen domains zum wohl aller in
die verschiedenen länder gebracht und dort ausgebaut werden heute betrachten viele staaten ihre
domain deshalb als wichtige nationale ressource in fast jedem land der welt unterliegen sie
einer form von direkter oder indirekter staatlicher kontrolle aber leider ist die vergabe dieser
länder domains in einigen fällen trotz postels grundregeln ziemlich übel gelaufen viele kleine
weniger entwickelte länder hatten zu dem zeitpunkt keine ahnung hat hat sie hat sie land eigentlich
den top level domain mein lieblings in anführung von inselstaat weiß gar nicht ob es überhaupt
noch gibt
guck das ist übrigens sie lernt es ist eine ehemalige bohr insel wo
irgendeiner rauf gefahren ist mit dem schiff und hat gesagt es ist jetzt mein eigenes land
internet überhaupt war einige dieser die haben die haben dann auch hosting angeboten hatten
vielleicht glück mit ihren länder codes aber keinen plan wie viel eine gute domain wert sein
könnte und so wurden sie teils einfach ausgebeutet tuvalu ist ein winziger inselstaat im pazifischen
ozean mit knapp 12.000 einwohnern das land hatte unfassbar viel glück denn tuvalus tld ist tv die
domain ist spätestens seit twitch äußerst beliebt weil naja tv und content und naja ihr
checkt schon punkt tv wurde direkt zur anfangszeit des internets einfach von einem amerikanischen
programmierer beansprucht der nichts mit tuvalu zu tun hatte tuvalu hat es allerdings recht
schnell geschaffen die folger sagen wo ist denn jetzt die dunkle wahrheit um ihn zurück zu
bekommen danach gab es viele interessanten aufstrebende amerikanische internet firmen mit
viel geld das kleine land mit kaum it expertise war ziemlich überfordert man unterschrieb einen
richtigen am start mit der amerikanischen firma veris sein oje oje moment sind nicht die das die
in hutki verloren haben oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander nicht es war komodo die in hutki
verloren haben das unternehmen sollte die domains für den inselstaat für die nächsten zwölf jahre
verkaufen tuvalu bekam dafür zwei millionen dollar pro jahr das waren zu dem zeitpunkt immerhin
rund 15 prozent des gesamten brutto inlandsprodukt der insel und veris seins infrastruktur hat es
dem land überhaupt erst ermöglicht die tv domains im großen stil ist das wo du als
zertifizierungsstelle quasi die kies für andere leute mit signiert ausstellst das heißt wenn
jemand ein hutki cloud kannst du im namen von einer zertifizierungsstelle dir selbst zertifikate
ausstellen den allen trauen kaufen aber gemessen an dem schieren potential und der beliebtheit von
punkt tv waren die zwei millionen pro jahr eher mager oder das war den das war den halt nicht
klar der einmaligen tuvalu finanzministers peanuts 2011 konnte aber jetzt mal ernsthaft
tuvalu hätte sich ja auch mal ein bisschen schlau machen können wenn irgendwie ein random dude zu
mir kommt und sagt ey max ich will das von dir unbedingt kaufen ich gebe dir zwei millionen für
das erste was ich mache ist erst mal zu gucken ok was will er eigentlich von mir und und was ist
das ja ich meine ich bin ja nicht gezwungen das instant morgen dir an den typ zu verkaufen also
die hätten ja auch mal ein bisschen gucken können und wenn das in den 90ern waren ist
wahrscheinlich zwei millionen für domains gar nicht mal so scheiße handeln und bekommt jetzt
immerhin fünf millionen dollar pro jahr der inselstaat wurde in gewisser weise von einem
großen konzern ausgenutzt und hat für mindestens ein jahrzehnt viel zu wenig geld bekommen aber
immerhin die haben die haben den kram unterschrieben mehr näher ich weiß ich kann mich da auch nicht
beschweren wenn ich irgendwie krepp unterschreiben und danach muss ich mich dran halten mitreden
niue hat es da viel härter erwischt nu habe ich schon nie gesehen niue ist ein winzig kleiner
inselstaat im südpazifischen ozean mit circa 1600 einwohner 1997 hat sich der amerikaner bill
sammich die kontrolle über punkt nu gesichert das ist die top level domain des landes sammich
hatte einen deal mit der regierung von niue er bekam alle rechte für punkt nu im gegenzug
sollte die insel gratis internet bekommen die niojanische regierung konnte zu diesem zeitpunkt
nicht ahnen was dieser amerikaner ihnen hier eigentlich abkaufte auf der anderen seite der
erde wird punkt nu schnell zu einem hit auf niederländisch dänisch und schwedisch bedeutet
nämlich jetzt sammich verdient sich in den folgenden jahren dumm und dämlich mit punkt
nu domains 2013 lizenziert er die rechte schließlich an die schwedische internetstiftung
internet was für ein ding die schwedische internetstiftung dabei hat niue schon im jahr 2000
gesetzlich festgelegt dass ihre domain eine nationale ressource ist über die der niojanische
staat entscheidet trotzdem hat ihnen niemand ihre domain zurückgegeben weder bill sammich noch die
schwedische stiftung aber hey der philanthrop sammich versorgt niue gemäß des deals doch
immerhin gratis mit internet das klingt ja voll großzügig und so das hier ist die webseite der
entsprechenden stiftung von sam einfach einfach mal ein mast gebaut und das sind halt versorgung
excellent ist ja fast ist ja fast wie bei uns die usn stiftung hilft schwellen denn dann dabei in
die internationale internet community einzutreten naja das gratis internet für die bevölkerung der
insel war schon immer das absolute minimum und hat nie auch nur im ansatz alle 1500 bürger
erreicht vielleicht symbolisch das hier ist das internet der usn stiftung
ok das ist echt aber immerhin eine klimaanlage da ist ja mein serverraum mehr high tech ich
meine was meint ihr wie das ding von innen aussieht ich glaube da bin ich fast schon besser dran ist
es ist es vielleicht ein telekom schalterhäuschen jedenfalls hat niue die schwedische internet
stiftung 2018 verklagt das ist per brumark ein schwedischer domain experte der niue in
diesem fall vertritt er schätzt dass dem inselstaat durch den verlust der punkt nu domain ungefähr
125 millionen euro umsatz entgangen sind dann wäre da noch punkt eo steht in it kreisen für
ja ok das das das kenne ich aber jetzt mal was zu punkt punkt tv also es ist in gewisser weise
schon verwerflich wenn du was sie ausnutzt dass die anderen keine ahnung haben aber da
muss man sich jetzt fragen ist das ist das jetzt echt der fail von den von den amis oder so in dem
fall also ich würde eher sagen das ist einmal natürlich die amis die das gnadenlos ausgenutzt
haben in dem fall aber auch letztendlich ein bisschen der fail von der regierung von
dua dingsbums ich habe vergessen wie sie heißen weil die hätten sich ja auch mal schlau machen
können also es wäre ihr shop ihr job gewesen sich mal schlau schlau zu machen tuvalu ja und in den
90ern weiß ich gar nicht mal ob zwei millionen für die domains so wenig waren ja und war so
letztendlich hat die regierung von tuvalu verkackt sich nicht schlau gemacht den kram unterschrieben
das ist so wie wenn ich damals für 10.000 bitcoins eine pizza bestellt habe und mich
heute rüber aufreg ich muss halt einfach gucken ich habe damals gesagt ich hätte gerne pizza
für 10.000 bitcoins und jemand hat mir eine pizza geliefert für 10.000 bitcoins ja hier
übergegeben und gut ist also ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich das so dunkel und verwerflich finden kann
ja mit 3 monate subscription und war deshalb lange ziemlich beliebt man hätte durchaus
in den vertrag genau man hätte den vertrag zum beispiel aufnehmen können dass das je nach
entwicklung irgendwie irgendwie was anderes passiert oder das nur zeitlich so und so beschränkt
ist oder dass es geknüpft ist an irgendwas ja also man hätte sich damals auch da irgendwas
holen kann es ist ja nicht so dass es irgendwie einen ureinwohner volk im busch ist das das
waren ja schon sonst hätten ja auch gar kein top level domain das waren halt welche die
saumäßig abgeschieden gelebt haben aber das war schon zivilisierte leute in dem sind die wussten die
haben nicht mehr gedacht die erde ist eine scheibe wobei das darf man ja so nicht sagen gibt es
immer noch welche ja also ich finde es jetzt nicht so verwerflich online games und web services die
domain gehört eigentlich zum british indian ocean territory das sind im prinzip die chargos
inseln und oh boy ist das eine düstere geschichte in kurzfassung ursprünglich gehören die chargos
inseln zu mauritius das ist ein inselstaat der wiederum von 1810 bis 1968 eine britische kolonie
war drei jahre vor der unabhängigkeit hat großbritannien die inselgruppe einfach von
mauritius abgetrennt und gesagt das ist ab jetzt das british indian ocean territory hat man ein
geheimes abkommen mit den usa geschlossen um dort eine gewaltige militärbasis zu errichten blöd
nur dass auf den inseln rund 2000 einheimische chargos inseln gelebt chargos inseln also was
es alles gibt zitat tatsahne und freitage hat man einfach kurzer hand das das wäre allein schon
allein schon die erwähnung wäre heute riesen skandal seitdem sind die inseln ein herrlicher
strategischer stützpunkt und es wurde sogar ein schönes kleines foltergefängnis der cia dort
hingepackt bis heute wurden die chargos inseln nicht an mauritius zurückgegeben und das obwohl
die un den britischen anspruch auf die inseln in mehreren instanzen niedergeschmettert hat ach so
natürlich haben die vertriebenen schagoschianer den juck des beinami ist das hier noch und die
domain wird von einem britischen unternehmen und die die uk leute juckt es auch nicht ein
wired artikel zu dieser thematik nennt diese fälle digitalen kolonialismus ist das übertrieben
hat er nicht ohne recht nur mit dem unterschied die haben eingewilligt es ist nicht so dass man
da mal wie damals hingefahren ist man hat man hat eine fahne aufgestellt und hat gesagt wir haben
jetzt hier das sagen und im zweifelsfall erschießen wir euch die haben immerhin freiwillig zugestimmt
das ist ja schon ein kleiner unterschied also ich meine jetzt die ersten nicht die letzten
stiftung schreibt uns gegenüber in einer stellungnahme ihre kontrolle der punkt nu domain
geschehe innerhalb der aufgestellten regeln schließlich sei bill sammich in den 90ern
rechtmäßig zum manager von punkt nu ernannt worden und er habe nur die administration übergeben
so sind domains wie punkt tv punkt nu oder punkt iow zu einem gewissen grad ein spiegel
der macht strukturen unserer zeit sie sind teil eines systems in dem jeder erstmal die gleichen
rechte hat aber letztlich gelten diese rechte dann doch etwas mehr für schweden als für
irgendeine insel im südpazifischen ozean für uns entblößen die geschichten dieser kürzel
eine bittere doppelmoral im harschen kontrast zu unseren gesellschaftlichen werten und dem
egalitären grundgedanken des internets winzig kleine nationen ihre ressourcen ihr digitales
öl wegzunehmen digitales öl ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen hochgegriffen irgendwo neokolonial
yes er hat schon nicht er hat irgendwo nicht unrecht hoffentlich aber gerade bei den ersten
weiß ich nicht ob ich das jetzt so dunkel oder oder so extrem verwerflich finden soll
wie das dargestellt hat selig haben sie die schon haben sie schon irgendwo gescampt aber
zumindest gescampt mit zustimmung nicht dass du trotz gescampt
wo empfiehlst du eine domain zu holen kann ich dir nichts empfehlen also ich habe bei denen hier
meine domains geholt aber die sacken weil die keine dns api haben und ich bin auch nur noch
nur noch da weil ich da ein paar domains habe und weil die billig als fack waren
nee was das gucke ich nicht an das habe ich damals auch gesagt hier also solang das so
ich bin nicht gegen irgendwelche verträge die rechtlich fragwürdig sind ja aber ich
habe damals auch schon gesagt wo es bei diese ganz kann sich noch einer an diese sache freiheit
für unge erinnern ich habe damals auch gesagt alter wenn man halt die sache unterschreibt nur
weil man es nicht besser weiß ist man selber dran schuld und das sagt ich als jemand der genau den
gleichen scheiß hatte der war weiß natürlich nicht so groß ist und nicht so viel sachen auf
sich gezogen hat ja ich hatte genau den gleichen scheiß wie er mit einem mit einem youtube netzwerk
nur dass ich damals nicht einfach quitten konnte weil in england gesessen haben ich
finde das auch ich finde das genauso scheiße aber eins ich habe das wichtige ist ja was man
daraus lernt was ich daraus gelernt habe ist man muss sich den scheiß wird also muss es wörtlich
nehmen was in so einem vertrag drinne steht nicht nach dem motto was also was was gemma was gemma
gerne machen ist sie erzählen dir was oder was heißt es gemma ja doch gemma sammas kömmers
gemma denn also was gemma gerne machen ist sie erzählen dir irgendwas was du geil findest dann
schicken sie ihren vertrag in dem steht das ein bisschen anders formuliert drinne aber sagen sie
sagen dann ja nee das das ist schon so wie ich dir gesagt habe aber wir brauchen das nur dass es
rechtlich konform ist oder sowas ja und dann und dann und dann unterschreibst du den scheiß du
musst das und das ist wirklich eine sache die ich mittlerweile gelernt habe also spätestens
seit der youtube netzwerk steht du musst das wirklich so nehmen wie es da drin steht wenn
da sachen drinne stehen die man eventuell zu deinen ungunsten auslegen kann dann kannst du
von ausgehen die werden zu deinen ungunsten ausgelegt und das halt gelitten und wenn du
einen vertrag unterschreibst wo dann da steht der gericht stand ist london da bist schon mal
gefickt das würde ich nicht machen es sei denn es ist irgendwas wo du von deiner seite aus easy
beenden kannst ja also zum beispiel zum beispiel ja wenn du jetzt mit irgendeinem mit irgendeinem
scammer einen vertrag machst und sagen wir mal so sagen wir mal g2a hätte mit mir irgendwie
einen merkwürdigen vertrag gemacht und ich könnte ich könnte einseitig sagen ich halte mich da nicht
dran und ich könnte das einfach machen dann müsste mich ja g2a verklagen das werden sie
wahrscheinlich nicht machen aber bei youtube netzwerken ist das anders dein channel ist ja
gelingt zu diesem netzwerk das heißt du kannst nicht einfach einseitig sagen ich scheiß auf den
vertrag und bin weg die müssen dich freigeben zumindest war das früher so und das heißt da
musst du halt genau gucken wenn du in den mist unterschreibst mit gericht stand ist london du
bist auf drei jahre oder unendlich lang verpflichtet bla bla bla dann hast du halt dummes zeug
unterschrieben hatte ich genau das gleiche problem hatte ich auch und wir sind dann nur
rausgekommen weil der channel betreiber damals das netzwerk verkauft hat und uns gegen youtube
bedingungen verstoßen hat kann ich an der stelle vielleicht auch noch mal erzählen also wir waren
ja bei wie sind das in dem englischen netzwerk ganz am anfang ich habe halt das dumme gelaber
geglaubt damals noch und der typ hat irgendwann sein netzwerk der wollte uns da nicht mehr
rauslassen partout wir haben den kram unterschrieben youtube hat auch gesagt ja verklagt ihn halt wir
machen da nichts und wir sind da nur rausgekommen weil er hat das netzwerk verkauft und hat gegen
youtube bericht youtube bedingungen verstoßen in dem er und jetzt kommt seine eigenen videos
gestrickt hat der typ wollte uns damals unter druck setzen wir sollen den vertrag umstellen
lassen von seinem netzwerk auf das neue netzwerk und um uns unter druck zu setzen hat er quasi
videos von uns gestrickt also er hat quasi videos von seinem eigenen netzwerk gestrickt
ohne ohne sinn und verstand ja und das hat youtube dann nicht so gefallen
sonst wären wir da wahrscheinlich rausgekommen kommt zu bettel viel sechs wieder den wunsch
zettel video ich glaube ich habe sogar schon mal ich habe doch sogar schon video gemacht zu
bettel viel sechs in letzter zapp oder nicht ich habe ab und zu mal was gesagt zu bettel viel
sechs ja da habe ich doch mal was zugesagt wo ich weiß ich was ich denke aber aktuell kann
man dazu noch gar nichts sagen weil es gibt ja noch null infos
auf was für eine verdauer ist ein vertrag ausgelegt das kommt auf den vertrag an unser
vertrag damals war glaube ich für immer oder auf jeden fall für eine ewig lange zeit also
der vertrag wäre in deutschland absolut nicht gültig gewesen aber in uk hätte ich hätte
nach london gehen müssen die typ verklagen wenn viel sechs wird skill best matchmaking
haben ja die dofe vermutung habe ich auch die dofe vermutung habe ich auch
ja florian wenn es ein guter job ist dann ist er nicht schlimm wenn es was taugt
advanced dashboards zeige her da hat es genau das gleiche gemacht wie ich das ist auch in
amazon fire ich habe auch so ein dashboard an der wand hängen mit amazon fire aber nicht
mit smart things smart things sagt home assistant beste ja so sieht das ja so so ziemlich genau
sieht es bei mir an der wand auch aus also die spotify geduld und so ist da nicht drauf aber
so ungefähr sieht es bei mir an der wand auch aus beste ach ja und bei den amis bei den amis
hast du den großen vorteil die kona bauweise erlaubt ja dass man mit einer säge einfach
löcher in die wand sägt matze vielleicht gibt es kein server browser mehr und das geht ja bei
uns nicht skill best matchmaking sorgt auch dafür dass sie noobs keinen spaß haben weil
es weil es durch die bank weg bei allen dafür sorgt dass sie quasi immer drei haben müssen
um ihre 50 50 zu haben also im prinzip macht es eigentlich für alle weniger spaß bin ich
der überzeugung das einzige was es bringt ist dass die hersteller irgendwelche microtransaktions
pushen können die ami häuser sind ja aus kona häuser sind ja aus holz eigentlich ich mache
mich ja immer so lustig zu lustig drüber über die ami ich finde die idee von holzhäusern gar
nicht mal so doof ich meine wenn man das in irgendeinem wirbelsturm gebüt gebiet macht ist
schon fail und dann muss man sich nicht wundern warum die häuser weg fliegen aber sich finde ich
die idee gar nicht schlecht das lässt sie schneller einfach und billiger bauen und um bauen als
steinhäuser übrigens wenn es unleashed ist und es ist günstiger wenn es unleashed ist das ich
bin mir nicht so ganz sicher warum die hatten eine ganze zeit lang memory ich weiß nicht ob das weg
ist aber es ist es ist das ich verstehe es nicht so genau weil eigentlich hat sich richtig gut
gespielt aber gibt 9 ja ja battlefield 3 übers battle lock ist noch was los ja also ich muss ja
auch sagen wenn ich finde ich spiele sich auch besser als vanilla so die besten gaming monitor
hier was gucken wir uns jetzt an mini raspberry pi silent homelab ok zeit mal her ich ich ich
call es jetzt schon mal es ist komplett sinnlos und eigentlich eher so ein bastelprojekt als dass
es was bringt ja nach dem wenn es release kam nicht mehr viel das ist echt problematisch
aber nicht jeff from the overwatch team kann er das noch kann er noch leiser reden vielleicht
ok wir spulen jetzt bisschen vor ich will nämlich sehen was was er was er baut parts
auf geht's nettes hübsches rack hat er da hübsches hübsches mini rack hat er da unten ist ist das
eine usb oder oder zumindest zumindest irgendwie so ein stromverteilungsding ist aber ist der raum
schräg oder ist die kamera schräg ich vermute mal die kamera ist schräg aber es sieht aus als
wäre der raum schräg wobei kokona kokona baubeisen man weiß nie vielleicht ist der
raum schräg holzhaus was hältst du von oder kann ich mal da kann ok leute kurze kurze
laberunterbrechung was hältst du von payson als erste programmiersprache ich muss unbedingt
ein video zu diesem thema machen weil das gibt es jeden stream diese frage und nicht nur einmal
also ich bin der meinung die beste einstiegs programmiersprache wenn man auch nicht genau
weiß was man machen will aktuell nach aktuellem stand ist javascript im browser javascript html
css allein schon aus dem grund weil du dann siehst was passiert und man an webentwicklung
ähnlich vorbeikommt heutzutage wenn du allerdings schon weißt und man kann auch wunderbar mit mit
javascript die die basics lernen ja so wenn du allerdings schon weißt was du machen willst dann
gibt es ein paar andere sachen die sich anbieten würden ja also wenn du zum beispiel weißt du
möchtest irgendwelche geschichten machen oder vielleicht server automatisierung scripting sonst
was oder dinge die sich halt in payson anbieten dann spricht da absolut nichts dagegen das als
erste sprache zu nehmen das ist eine super programmiersprache zum anfang auf jeden fall
ja da kann man sich gleich schon mal dran gewöhnen dass alle programmiersprachen irgendwelche
wirren dinge haben was hältst du von assembler als erste programmiersprache welchen assembler
denn ja gut java also payson ist eine gute programmiersprache zum einstieg ruby auch
allerdings ist ruby an sich nicht mehr so angesagt ich persönlich mag ja c sharp und dotnet auch
als einstieg ja viel leichter wenn du eine programmiersprache kannst lernst du die anderen
in zwei drei tagen soweit dass sie gut benutzen kannst du lernst dann weniger die programmiersprache
du lernst dann mehr die standard library von den sprachen wenn du was kannst wenn du eine
sprache kannst und 10 plus plus würde ich auf keinen fall zum einstieg machen also wie gesagt
ich bin auch großer fan von dort netz die scharp zum programmieren einsteigen weil der vorteil von
sie scharp ist ich finde es ist die aktuell universalste programmiersprache die es gibt was
du machen kannst du kannst von server anwendung bis zu web anwendung bis zu gui anwendung cross
platform sachen du kannst alles machen und das ganze in einer schönen sprache du magst das
eventuell auch in c plus plus machen können aber c plus plus ist eine kacke sprache und sie scharp
ist eine hübsche sprache ja du kannst fast alles so sieht es aus du kannst fast alles in sie scharp
machen es gibt ein paar sachen wo ich jetzt sagen würde das geht geht schlecht beste programmiersprache
zum ausstieg kobold würde ich sagen oder mal zu zum aufstieg zum aufstieg vielleicht übrigens
leute der herr n punkt hat sich bei mir gemeldet aus dem letzten video habe ich euch das eigentlich
erzählt als bei mir hat es bei mir im discord gemeldet richtig poc ja so also es gibt ein paar
sachen und ja und er sagt er macht immer noch IT hat er erzählt so du kannst fast alles gut das
stimmt es gibt ein paar sachen die mir einfallen die nicht gut in sie scharp gehen wie gesagt
ein boot manager oder so kannst du nicht unbedingt machen ein betriebssystem rein in sie scharp ist
wahrscheinlich auch nichts aber ansonsten von meinetwegen von smartphone anwendung geht ist
vielleicht nicht so schön zu cross platform gui sachen zu web anwendung zu server sachen du kannst
alles drin machen also ich finde deswegen ist sie scharpen schöner einstieg weil sie scharpe
kannst du alles mitmachen du kannst theoretisch mit sie scharpe anfangen und nie was anderes
machen und trotzdem mehr oder weniger alles programmieren ja habe ich schon gehört habe
ich auch nichts mitgemacht mitnehmen etwas kann ich nicht verstehen dass die die leute also die
leute die sowas denken müssen nicht mal ganz dicht sein also wie man also wie man c++ lieben kann
erschließt sich mir schon mal gar nicht aber im umkehrzug sie scharpe hassen kann weiß ich auch
nicht also sie scharpe ist eine wunderbar zum größten teil konsistente und nachvollziehbare
sprache also das komplette gegenteil von c++ das ist auch ein vorteil ja dass du ältere ältere
scharpe und net version in windows mit eingebaut hast aber du kannst auch wunderbar standalone
anwendung mittlerweile machen ohne dass das framework installieren muss ja ja das war
der originale swift so swift kann ich nicht sagen habe ich nichts mitgemacht nein ich
finde es nicht sinnvoll sampler in der schule zu machen schon gar nicht zum einstieg am anfang
würde ich teile skript weglassen wenn ich ganz neu einsteigen damit einfach nur java skript machen
ne microsoft schafft es nicht mal ein ordentliches windows framework rauszubringen winui 3.0 hat sich
gut gelesen aber sie haben es nicht auf die reihe gekriegt ich weiß nicht was microsoft
macht und die müssen sich nicht wundern die müssen sich nicht wundern wenn alle welt elektron
anwendung macht du brauchst also wenn es nen wenn es ein dotnet core projekt ist ist es easy
um dotnet core projekt zu bilden brauchst du noch nicht mal eine idee das hast du einfach dotnet
run und gut ist uvp sagt einfach nur hardcore die mögen ja uvp selber nicht mehr deswegen haben
jetzt winui gemacht was quasi uvp weiterentwickelt und für mehr anwendungstypen zu benutzt werden
kann aber sie haben es immer noch nicht geschafft unpackaged apps zu machen das wichtigste was man
bräuchte unter windows ja es holt sich doch keiner den code signing zertifikat einfach mal random
wenn er sagt auch ich könnte auch nur windows anwendung machen dann läuft das darauf raus dass
die leute anfangen elektron zu verwenden als groß plattform framework was eigentlich für alle
beteiligten sagt naja gut gucken wir mal weiter was haben wir sonst noch hier schönes zu bieten
excellent pie cluster pongas teams ist mit elektron gemacht ja das ergibt aber auch sinn
weil teams im browser laufen soll was hat er da mini kabel sind es in der net key oder so
das ist okay leute ernsthaft das sind die kürzesten netzwerkabel die ich je gesehen habe
cut the fit specifically for the rack in we have these little data to usb for the
that sind die sind aus egypten deswegen haben die so eine pyramiden form asperry pie drives
ist es hat er das nee das ist moment das hat er nicht 3d gedruckt oder das sieht so metal an aus
ok leute leute ich muss mal kurz suchen man kann sich man kann sich rack mounds 3d drucken gescheit
die halten dann auch moment moment moment moment da muss man kurz kurz singiverse anschmeißen
und noch schnell schauen wobei warum mache ich eigentlich meine vm dafür an ist doch komplett
hängen geblieben dann lasse ich das video hier im fullscreen und gut ist
das muss ich mir mal kurz angucken das muss ich mal kurz kurz kurz musik anmachen wieder
wait a minute wait a minute keck wait keck wait singiverse
da in das netzwerk ist nicht disconnected sonst könnte sie jetzt rack rack mount mount print
print 3d steve das da guck mal hier hey das ist cool das trotter aber doch bestimmt in
einzelnen teilen aus gibt es gibt es auch so was wo einfach wo man einfach nur was drauf stellt
hey das ist cool wow ok jetzt wird übertrieben ist ja gut ist ja ist ja gut übertreibt man nicht
eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs sieben acht neun zehn elf zwölf 13 habe ich erzählt habe ich
erzählt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 das steht 12 hat er sich verzählen ich bin ich jetzt
erzähl keck wait bracket bracket eins mit dem intervall achso das kann man nicht alles
rein stöpseln guck mal sogar metall macht die hier hinten dran das auch eine 3d gedruckte unterlage
moment wie soll ich denn das rack mounten ach nur auf einer seite festschrauben oder was das check
ich nicht wie das funktioniert ist mir zu hoch ja nur auf einer seite festschrauben hier festschrauben
hey das ist eigentlich eine coole idee da kann man den respekt an einer seite fest hängen
interessant was nicht was hier moment das ist dass ich was rack mounten das unter meinem
schreibtisch mounten kann eigentlich auch eine coole sache nicht dass ich es brauchen würde aber
okay gucken wir weiter man kann excellent 3d drucken finde ich echt nice wobei das eigentlich
ganz cool wäre da könnte ich meinen das ist nice ich habe mir doch diesen switch hier gekauft der
ist doch der ist auch führen für den schreibtisch habe ich mir den gekauft eigentlich war mein plan
ich stelle den auf den schreibtisch drauf aber hier werden hier werden ja so ein rack mount
mitgeliefert auf einer seite es reicht auf einer seite weil das ding ist nicht so schwer oder vielleicht
doch auf beiden seiten mal gucken außerdem habe ich noch so brackets übrig den könnte ich mir
eigentlich hinten unter den schreibtisch hängen anstatt auf den schreibtisch zu stellen auf der
anderen seite komme ich dann schlecht dran da muss jedes mal unter den tisch krabbeln
mal mal überlegen gucken wir gucken wir erst mal weiter was baut er dann sonst noch
das ist auf jeden aber das finde ich das finde ich auf jeden fall schon mal nice dass man sich das
ausdrucken kann die switch die festplatte der cloud controller hat ein unify controller
und dann die router so diese sind ziemlich interessant weil sie hier schrauben also kannst du sie eigentlich ausnehmen und sie in verschiedene Formen kombinieren
was war das war das ein tp link habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen ja ist tp link ist mittlerweile glaube
ganz brauchbar ich hatte auch jahrelang so den billigsten vom billigsten also wirklich das aller
aller aller billigste tp link switch mit im netzwerk hat nie probleme gemacht also unmanaged und 5 euro
oder sowas der gekostet aber ich habe ich nicht gesehen ist ja witzig also wenn
noch nicht mal rockstar jason passen kann warum passen überhaupt jason selbst kann man nicht
einfach eine jason library verwenden die das für ein macht man muss man muss doch nicht jeden mist
nach programmieren das glaube ich dir nicht da erzählt er uns mist der hat garantiert schon
probiert ob es reinpasst man wäre einfach total bescheuert wenn man ein video aufnimmt um zu
zeigen wie man zusammen baut und vorher nicht probiert hat ob es reinpasst dann müsste man
nämlich einfach wenn es nicht reinpasst das video ins und aus machen also das garantiert
hat es vorher ausprobiert und jetzt leute leute huge huge reveal huge massive reveal ich habe
euch auch schon mist erzählt in videos ich habe auch schon in videos gesagt ich probiere das jetzt
zum ersten mal aus und in wirklichkeit habe ich vorher schon mal ausprobiert
huge leak ich weiß hätte hätte man nie gedacht vorher aber scripted ja
das abo de abo lügenpresse alles raus ja so sieht es aus so sieht es aus ja revealed
legt bestimmt auch an 5g anzeige ist raus des abo macht man guck mal wie gut das passt
ja du hältst ja auch fest der hält ja auch fest
ok mal ein bisschen weiter da ist aber ganz schön gehen aber kaum rein
so ok wir schwimmen ein bisschen vor ich meine es sieht ohne mist für selbst
gedruckt sieht das ziemlich gut aus wofür ist der cloud controller das frage ich mich auch
was da wie controlled ist es dieser tp link unify abklatsch den die jetzt gemacht haben
was er da als cloud control tp link hat auch jetzt so den unify abklatsch
hat er aber das gain an seinem mikrofon hochgedreht stimmt perfekt fit ob es wohl passt ok weiter
weiter poe ah der macht die raspberries poe da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt wie er das macht also
was ich kenne ist es gibt so adapter die splitten dein poe zu netzwerk und einem usb c stecker für
den raspberry pi die kenne ich aber es wäre richtig cool wenn man mal den raspberry pi
bekommen würde der eingebautes poe hat ja ok die die diese karten gibt es auch noch
und wie kriegt man da jetzt poe dran
wie macht man als poe dran weil ich mein rein ins netzwerk reinstecken bringt ja auch
nichts wenn der hat da oben drauf ist oder wie kriegt man als den strom dran wie soll
denn das schild vom netzwerk anschluss den strom bekommen da sind vier extra pins ja genau und
wie kommt es aus dem netzwerk kabel an die vier extra pins über gpio wie kommt es aus dem
netzwerk kabel an die gpio pins du hast den rf 45 stecker wie kommt das von den adern auf
der strom auf auf netzwerk kabel drauf ist auf die gpio pins irgendwie muss das dahin
kommen über den netzwerk anschluss wird es nicht funktionieren
wireless strom 5g ja ok das passt 5g ist im zweifelsfall kriegt das alles brauchbar ja
ok machen wir sie schneller es sieht fast ein bisschen aus wie bei mir mit den kabel farben
ich habe es auch so gemacht dass ich rote kabel jetzt habe da wo es intern also zu unity
media geht nee schwachsinn stimmt gar nicht ich habe pinkel kabel für ablink zum internet
ich habe rote kabel für poe sieht man ja sieht man ja hier also ok hier sieht man das
noch nicht weil hier ist noch bevor ich ordentlich gemacht habe aber die roten kabel sind für
poe ok viel passiert da glaube ich nicht mehr was ich mich jetzt nur frage ist but why ich
meine könnte er sich nicht einfach ein low power intel da rein stellen der schneller
ist als zwei pies und wahrscheinlich auch noch einfacher zu managen ich meine es geht
nicht das ist auf jeden fall nice ich habe ja auch ein raspberry pi drin aber der hängt
bei mir halt auf dem 3d trocker hier oben drauf der übrigens so gar nicht mehr aussieht
ich habe mittlerweile den raspberry pi getauscht und einen im gehäuse dahingestellt bei mir
ist nee wlan ist bei mir nicht blau also für die access points sondern auch rot weil die
access points über poe gehen da hat mich übrigens der chat auf die idee gebracht der chat hat
mich auf die idee gebracht ich habe einfach an 48 volt netzteil an den switch angeschlossen
und kann jetzt ordentlich poe machen für die für die access points deswegen habe ich mir
auch den top charger bestellt weil das sind 48 volt 2 oder 3 ampere netzteil ist den braucht
man ja braucht für den switch drückt hier doch ein gehäuse kann ich auch machen aber
wozu ich meine ich kann den einfach hier oben drauf ich habe da unten drunter so ein klebeding
gemacht und jetzt habt so umdruf es gibt hinter der bukse vier pins die gehen an das hätt
ok das ergibt natürlich schon das wäre werkzeug ja das ist wahrscheinlich das teuerste an
dem ganzen werkzeug schrank das wäre werkzeug na wobei die 3d drucker und das was drin ist
waren jetzt gerade nee ist es nicht der switch alleine kostet ja schon 550 euro aber die
maul der maul schlüsselsatz so geiler zu benutzen ist so selten braucht man ihn wenn
man nicht gerade irgendwie automechaniker ist ist eigentlich ehrlich gesagt viel zu
teuer ich weiß nicht was mich da geritten hat warum ich mir den maul schlüsselsatz
gekauft habe ich mein joker set ich meine 173 euro das ist wirklich monka s alter die
gibt es übrigens noch teurer die gibt es übrigens noch teurer es gibt noch die abgewinkelte
variante das ist glaube ich die abgewinkelte variante die kostet 234 noch teurer also
wie das coole an denen ist also wäre hat auch noch die normalen die die ohne ratchet die
sind ein bisschen günstiger gibt sie überhaupt noch gab es nicht auch welche ohne ratchet
wie dem auch sei dass das ist das set was ich mir und das ist echt nice also das macht
ultra bock damit was zu schrauben ich wusste letztens beispielsweise den tisch wieder fest
schrauben wo ich hier meine meine meine lötmatte drauf hab und wo ich auch im stream schon
von gestreamt hab also dieser tisch mit der kamera oben drüber und im ring light der hat
sich ein bisschen verzogen weil er die ganze zeit an der heizung stand und es halt ein
bisschen lockerer geworden ich hätte mir übelst einen abgebrochen hätte ich da unter
dem tisch mit normalen maul schlüsseln schlüsseln müssen und hier die ratchet aufgesetzt 20
sekunden eine seite 20 sekunden andere seite innerhalb von zwei minuten war das ding wieder
bombenfest also echt echt huge des sets echt geil ja und warum ich das hier so hingehängt
hab ist ganz einfach hat zwei gründe erstens kommt man hier schön einfach dran zum rausziehen
und zweitens kann man damit gut posen das ist natürlich auch ein wichtiger punkt wenn
man so teures werkzeug hat so mal schnell durch scrollen ok was er da genau vor hat
ich check es absolut nicht aber es ist auf jeden fall optisch schon mal nicht schlecht
max wo schaust du nach ob sie steckdosen flaschen lassen und welche nicht also die beste tas motor
datenbank ist database plege plege er oder wie das das da das ist somit mit die beste
datenbank wo du nachgucken kannst auch die settings für die geräte suchen wir zum beispiel
mal das ding jetzt raus was ich letztens eben was wir zusammen im stream geflasht haben
das war das hier glaube zumindest dass wir das im stream gemacht haben so dann siehst
du hier ok das lässt sich prinzipiell flaschen und sonst was aber aber das ist halt nur eine
momentaufnahme das hat mal irgendwann einer gekauft und geflasht das heißt nicht dass
ich das aktuell noch flaschen lässt bei manchen bei manchen haben sie den hinweis drinne wenn
sich einer beschwert hat dass es nicht mehr geht dass hinweist dass es jetzt nicht mehr
so sein könnte ansonsten hast du echt ein problem es gibt keine wirklich aktuelle quelle
weil sich das permanent ändern kann je nach dem firmwährstand der der hardware ja was
halt tatsächlich bisschen doof ist was du machen kannst ist mal angenommen du suchst
auf amazon ja gehst du mal mit amazon nach amazon suchen das teil ja das hier zum beispiel
gehst du bei amazon rein ich mache mal kurz flashbang du kannst hier suchen nach du kannst
suchen nach tuja einmal ist nicht schlecht und nach tasmotor so und da siehst du schon
neue firmwähr tasmotor ota geht nicht tja da siehst du es ist aktuell nicht mehr möglich
die zu flaschen hier mitte des jahres ging es noch letzte ende letzten jahres ging es
nicht mehr allerdings die letzte chance die du hast was es bringt so was zu flaschen zum
beispiel dass ich den steckdosen leist über das webinterface steuern kann die hier ist
zum beispiel für ein 3d drucker kann ich mein 3d drucker remote anschalten und sie
sogar den stromverbrauch weiter bei das webinterface ist nur ein teil ich habe es in meiner ich
habe es in meiner heim automatisierung drinne in meiner heim automatisierung drinne dass
ich das ganze machen kann exzellent sieht bei mir aktuell so aus ich hoffe ich kann euch
das mal zeigen ohne dass ich was leake exzellent jawoll so sieht das aktuell aus das ist das
ist das die karte für das ist übrigens meine mein test home assistant ich habe ha und
hau hau ist das teste testing ding und so sieht das aktuell aus das heißt sprich hier kann
ich jetzt also sprich das hier dieser schalter ist der eigentliche von von dieser steckdose
kann ich mein 3d drucker an ausschalten die habe ich noch auf einem schreibtisch die
ganzen stecker steckdosen leiste hier ist der switch angeschlossen hier kann ich usb
an und aus machen hier habe ich eine steckdose an einer eingangstür dann habe ich noch drei
freie auf dem schreibtisch 123 habe ich durchgelabelt das ist rgb fensterbeleuchtung rgb an der
decke hier muss übrigens auch das ring light rein das ring light fehlt noch was neben
mir hängt und hier kann ich noch die heizung einstellen ja und zum flaschen was auch noch
nice ist man kann zum beispiel auch so sachen wie sein staubsauger flaschen und dann bekommt
man den webinterface von seinem staubsauger ich könnte jetzt den staubsauger da hinschicken
wenn ich dahin klicke aber will ich nicht verwirrt die katz exzellent ja leider leider
nicht das habe ich auch auf die habe ich auch in auge geworfen offline nur über wlan korrekte
brauchst keine klaut mehr ja und wie gesagt hiermit kann ich jetzt mein 3d drucker ein
ausschalten deswegen lohnt sich das zu flaschen ja du kannst damit auch automatisch die dosen
fern steuern ja kannst du machen das kannst du machen kannst zeit steuern nach sonnenaufgang
steuern nach anderen events steuern alles was steuern willst wie geht das mit der heizung
ich hatte die ganze zeit so ein sickbeat thermostat die waren aber kacke ich habe ein bisschen
mit den dingern rum experimentet die sacken aber und jetzt habe ich habe ich tatsächlich
die rote pest aus berlin am start an den heizungen hier habe ich aber nicht an allen im ganzen
haus nur da wo ich regeln will da habe ich tatsächlich fritz fritz dinger die funktionieren
bisher echt ziemlich gut muss ich sagen die haben nur einen nachteil die haben nur einen
großen nachteil die sind ein bisschen langsam was das schalten angeht was nicht so schlimm
ist für eine thermostat ja ob das jetzt fünf minuten früher oder später angeht ist egal
aber zum strom sparen rufen die sich den stand plus alle 15 minuten mal ab man kann allerdings
jedes man kann mit dem drücken auf ok das jedes mal triggern also die haben den delay
von 15 von maximal 15 minuten je nachdem nein die habe ich nicht mit das motor geflecht
die sind standard standard firmware aber die standard firmware ist ok und braucht keine
cloud oder sonst was und lässt sich den home assistant einbinden ja das nächste ist eine
sehr gute frage wie hast du eigentlich local HTTPS geregelt selbst sein ne weder noch cloud
flair dns let's encrypt dns challenge ja wie gesagt ich habe die steckdosen aber nicht
kaufen nicht kaufen ich habe die hier unter anderem ich habe ich habe total viele verschiedenen
weil ich immer gucke ob man die grad flaschen kann ob man die grad flaschen kann das hängt
ganz entscheidend davon ab welchen stand die steckdosen haben wenn sie ausgeliefert werden
also als ich mir die gekauft habe konnte man sie noch flaschen moment moment ich erzähle
den mist das stimmt gar nicht die konnte man auch nicht flaschen die musste ich ja aufschrauben
leute stimmt nicht die sachen die ich flaschen konnte waren die anderen flashchamp.org die
musste ich aufschrauben die musste ich aufschrauben genau da habe ich eine anleitung gefunden
irgendwo in die niederländische anleitung das da kann es glaube ich sein genau da habe
ich die anleitung gefunden welche pins was sind stimmt stimmt die musste ich flaschen
über hier über tims nein das war nicht die die ich aufgebrochen habe die die ich aufgebrochen
habe im stream waren die waren die doppelten die ich im stream aufgebrochen habe waren
die gosund sp ich glaube die da die habe ich im stream aufgebrochen die doppelten die da
wobei sich die hätten theoretisch eigentlich noch flaschen lassen müssen aber die haben
sich auch nicht flaschen lassen deswegen die musste ich aufmachen das war auch ein ganz
schöner akt da musste man hier neben mit dem schraubendreher sehr sehr ordentlich hebeln
dass man die aufbekommt also komplett ohne rückstände am gehäuse ging es nicht also
meine haben jetzt an der seite hier überall so eine kleine dalle wo ich die aufgehebelt
habe und im prinzip habe ich so genauso gemacht wie in der anleitung also sprich ich habe
jetzt aufgemacht habe an die pins meinen flasher dran gelötet also flasher man braucht so
nen f t d i sowas da in der richtung braucht man die muss man anschließen dann ein rechner
und dann kann man vom computer oder vom raspberry pi aus flaschen also sprich man lötet hier
die kabel an am besten paar jumper kabel die man einfach wieder ab machen kann oder man
nimmt so welche die man hier rein stecken kann und dann schließt man das an raspberry
pi und flascht das motor drauf ist ein bisschen größere akt aber ich kann euch sagen wenn
ihr es mal gemacht habt das geht wenn man ein bisschen übung hat relativ schnell also
wenn ihr wenn ihr wenn ihr euch keine angenommen ihr kauft euch ein achter pack steckdosen
und bei den ersten braucht ihr eine halbe stunde pro steckdose und zum schluss braucht
ihr eine viertel stunde mit ein bisschen übung viertel stunde pro steckdose aber besser ist
natürlich sie lassen sich flaschen übers wlan und das hängt halt ganz entscheidend
von der firme von der firmware version ab und die hier waren zu neu die konnte ich nicht
mehr übers wlan flaschen es gibt auf github dieses dieses projekt damit kann man versuche
mit einem raspberry pi übers wlan die steckdosen zu zu flaschen die machen das ganz trickreich
die geben sich irgendwie die machen den wlan auf was so heißt wie das wlan wo die steckdosen
initial quasi geflascht werden beim china hersteller und dann machen sie komische dinger
und überlisten die die die steckdosen mit alter firmware dass sie denken sie werden
gerade vom hersteller geflascht das funktioniert allerdings halt nicht bei allem wir können
mal die neuen releases gucken ob es da was neues gibt jetzt ist das erste release ja
also ihr seht die leute haben auch noch ganz schön probleme aber damit damit musst du
nicht mehr aufschrauben damit musst du nicht aufschrauben damit kannst du übers wlan flaschen
das ist dann relativ einfach ja genau also es ist es ist halt ein bisschen glück ob
es drauf ankommt also ob es klappt ja ne die flaschen wenn du die aufschraubst und kommst
an die pins dran dann kannst du gleich direkt die software flaschen die du flaschen willst
ne ne du musst halt aufschrauben da kannst du auch direkt flaschen leider leider geht
es halt nicht mehr bei allen geräten deswegen gucke ich immer vorher bei amazon lässt sich
das flaschen und hier ist es anscheinend so und hier schreiben ja auch viele bei amazon
dass das nicht mehr nicht mehr geht wenn man wenn man hier sucht ja ich sag tuja suchen
oder tas motor suchen und dann sieht man dass es nicht funktioniert hier sieht man mal
hier sieht man wir dass die chinesen nicht checken was der typ gefragt hat warum kommt
dann kein hersteller auf die dir sowas ohne klaut zu machen gibt es zum beispiel von shelly
shelly hat den dümmsten domain name ja shelly punkt klaut ein hauptsächliches feature
der geräte von shelly ist dass sie keine klaut brauchen das ist unglaublich dumm ich
weiß nicht warum man sich so eine bescheuerte domain macht also eines der hauptverkaufsargumente
ist dass es ohne klaut geht also die haben die haben sowas das ist halt teurer als der
china kram die haben noch mehr die haben auch kleine ja das ist halt das ist halt ein bisschen
teurer guck mal hier diese dosen bekommst du und die gibt es auch teilweise billiger
hier bekommst du vier dosen für 36 euro und wenn man es aus china land bestellen also
neun neun euro pro dose so ein shelly und shelly plug kostet 22 euro kriegt man vielleicht
auch ein bisschen ein bisschen besser im shelly shop aber das ist halt der preisliche unterschied
ja die sind einfach billiger die china dinger und wenn die sich flaschen lassen ist richtig
nice also du bezahlst ungefähr das doppelte für den shelly ding es gibt noch mehr hersteller
die es ohne klaut machen aber shelly ist somit das bekannteste gibt es gibt es aber die die
china dinger sind halt so beliebt weil im prinzip die gleiche hardware drin ist wie
bei den shellys also ein controller aber halt sie nur die hälfte kosten deswegen war das
auch so geil die zu flaschen die china teile genau so sieht es aus shelly geht komplett
offline ja wlan gut ist und die china dinger gehen nach dem flaschen ja auch komplett offline
wie gesagt ich kann hier euch ja gezeigt hier ich kann hier ich kann hier übers web interface
oder über mein heim automatisierung schalten ja na gut so das habe ich übersehen moin
welches audio interface mixer kannst du für das mx raunern keinen weil ich habe es an
meinem audio interface dran und das ist eigentlich zu teuer um es so zu empfehlen weil ich habe
mir das audio interface damals gekauft weil ich auch viel mehr dran angeschlossen habe
ich habe meine zwei pcs dran angeschlossen ich habe die konsole dran angeschlossen ich
habe die ganzen mikrophones dran angeschlossen mikrofone ich habe das da was geht ja um
neues das zeigt man ja aber das direktbauweise also ich habe das da hallo das habe ich mir
schon vor jahren gekauft das da genau das teil das kommt mit so einem breakout kabel
da kannst du hast du alle möglichen anschlüsse ja du hast mehrere kopfhörer ausgänge eingänge
mikrofon ein ausgänge also es ist wirklich top lohnt sich aber nicht weil es eigentlich
viel zu teuer wenn du einfach nur das mx 300 anschließen willst was viele leute empfehlen
für pc wenn du quasi nur einfach nur halbwegs qualitativ hochwertigen audio ausgang für
pc haben willst sind diese fio dinger habe ich persönlich aber noch nie ausprobiert
die dinger werden aber oftmals in audioforen empfohlen dass sie ganz gut sein sollen zeigen
die jelly plucks auch den stromverbrauch ja wenn du den richtigen jelly plug nimmst shop
die haben verschiedene die haben products relays plug and play genau ich glaube der
kann auch den stromverbrauch ich habe gesagt der ist halt mega hässlich glaube der kann
auch den stromverbrauch die haben auch viele sachen die sind relativ relativ braucht man
nicht unbedingt aber die haben die haben ganz gute sachen das hier würde ich mit billig
guck mal hier nen jelly door sensor kostet was ja meine güte 16 euro du kriegst für
sieben euro kriegst ein china ding der kann glaube ich auch strom messen also nicht strom
messen verbrauch ja power metering wobei es ja gar kein verbrauch in dem sinn gibt das
wird ja alles umgewandelt wird uns jetzt der physiker sagen energie erhaltung ja und gerade
so ein 3d drucker wandelt auch ganz wandelt recht viel um in der raum wird warm ja also
kannst du auch kannst du machen hecky genau so sachen finde ich immer richtig gut das
ist ein richtig gutes beispiel für wenn wenn leute hecky schreibt hier der plug s hängt
bei ihm an der waschmaschine schickt ihm im nachricht wenn es fertig ist das ist genau
das was ich immer sage wo es beim thema heim automatisierung darum geht es geht nicht nach
drum irgendwie 50 geräte anzuschließen dass man dann ein cooles dashboard hat um regelmäßig
auf sein tablet zu gucken und nie was zu verwenden worum es zumindest meiner meinung nach bei
heim automatisierung geht ist dinger die man immer wieder macht und die einen nerven oder
oder sagen wir mal dinger wo man wo man relativ easy am anfang durch kleinen kleine investitionen
schon viel komfort für sich rausholen kann das ist das wichtig also sprich mal angenommen
man hat die waschmaschine irgendwo im hof stehen in der garage gibt ja leute und ihr
wollt mitbekommen wann die fertig ist schließt in den schelle plug an den strom ist und den
verbrauch mist oder wie auch immer der korrekte bezeichnung für ist und lasst euch den nachricht
schicken wenn es denn dann fertig ist ja sowas bringt dann richtig was und es ist auch ein
mehrwert und jetzt nicht irgendwelche rgb beleuchtung weil weil rgb beleuchtung rgb
beleuchtung ist der ist das überschätzteste heim automatisierungsprodukt kategorie überhaupt
rgb beleuchtung braucht 95 prozent der leute nicht es ist komplett sinnlos in 95 prozent
der anwendungsweise keiner braucht rgb beleuchtung außer in den ganz seltenen fällen wohne rgb
beleuchtung tatsächlich sinnvoll ist die normale beleuchtung von einem raum reicht vollkommen
aus wenn es eine wenn es eine lampe ist die man an und ausschalten kann remote das kann
man übrigens mit so einem schelle relay wunderbar machen also 95 prozent 90 prozent der fälle
reicht das aus wenn man einfach nur an und ausschalten kann die lampe die schon da ist
zum beispiel mit so einem schelle relay easy so der nächste punkt ist wenn man wenn man
wirklich lampen steuern will in den nächsten 95 prozent der fälle reicht wenn die lampe
dimmbar ist dass man damit das machen kann was man will ja wenn man zum beispiel im wohnzimmer
möchte dass das licht bisschen dunkler wird wenn man den film anschaltet dann braucht
man eine dimmbare lampe ist deutlich deutlich günstiger als eine als eine rgb lampe zum
beispiel das ist der hersteller von dem ich mein rgb krams hab wenn du dir die sachen
einfach nur dimmbar kaufst dann kostet einfach die hälfte von dem normalen so der nächste
schritt ist nach dimmbar ist mit ich nenne es mal so weiß an gleich da kann man dann
beispielsweise einstellen wie weiß weiß ist also sprich wie rötlich oder blau oder das
ganze ist der vorteil ist ist auch noch mal die farbtemperatur ist auch noch mal billiger
weil du brauchst also dimmbar brauchst du eine led eine weiße eine weiße led brauchst
du dimmbar so für angleich temperature angleich also temperatur auswahl bei der lampe brauchst
du eine weiße led und wahrscheinlich mindestens noch eine rote led wenn die wenn die weiße
led relativ relativ bläulich hell ist so da brauchst du nur zwei und für rgb brauchst
du halt vier leds deswegen kosten hier auch mehr du brauchst eine weiße du brauchst
eine rote du brauchst eine grüne und eine blaue und deswegen ist meiner mein noch rgb
das überschätzte ding die meist leute hängen sich rgb hin verwenden aber zu 95 prozent
maximal dimmbar und vielleicht farbtemperatur ja und deswegen alles mit rgb auszustatten
was gelb nicht grün was natürlich grün gelb wie kommst du auf gelb das ist englisch das
ist red green blue und ich yellow blue jebaited alter brauchst du bei rgb nicht nur drei doch
theoretisch schon aber weiß sieht mit rgb bei lampen nicht gut aus das beste ist rgbw
also rot grün blau weiß nur so kriegst du auch ein ordentlich weißton hin da an die
technik für sowas ist es sinnvoll da hast du recht aber wahrscheinlich hast du halt
von ich sag jetzt einfach mal 20 lampen oder so hast du wahrscheinlich was ich zwei wurde
das rgb feature oder so verwendest also zu 95 prozent brauchen die leute dort wo sie
rgb lampen haben höchstens dimmbar meiner einschätzung nach vielleicht mal ein bisschen
mehr ein bisschen weniger aber wenn man sein haus mit smarter beleuchtung versorgen will
ist das das das beste was man am anfang machen kann das einfach sich in relay zu holen und
die bestehenden lampen zu verwenden und das nächste ist dann was zu holen was dimmbar
ist und eventuell die farbtemperatur einstellen kann man spart unglaublich viel geld dadurch
ja auch weil die leute hingehen und sagen ich will smart lighting smart lighting und
kaufen sich einfach mal 2030 rgb lampen da bist du ja da bist du ja schon mal was weiß
ich 1000 euro los so und kaufst du und kaufst du nur kaufst du einfach nur dimmbar da kostet
sich nur 300 euro wenn du mietes kannst du nicht einfach relays bauen bei der way ich
würde das sogar in einer mietwohnung machen du kannst es ja wieder ausbauen das ist ja
nix zerstört ja nix aber ja kann ich verstehen wenn man das nicht will man muss ja nichts
kaputt machen wenn man die relay einbaut ja man macht man macht den den den rahmen ab
von der also man macht erst mal die sicherung raus ja und man guckt sich tutorials an wie
es geht wenn man keine ahnung an dass wir sind elektriker machen genau die taster gehen
mit jelly weiterhin das ist ja gerade der sinn dahinter also du kannst ja quasi du
kannst ja den schalter weiter benutzen und trotzdem über deine heim automatisierung
einen ausschalten es gibt es gibt die schelle es gibt diese cellis und es gibt noch die
cellis die die die wenige anschlüsse brauchen vor allem ich bin ich der große elektro elektro
pro ja genau easy light das beste ist man macht lampen und relays weil weil weil weil
weil die sache ist die solange die lichtschalter noch funktionieren gibt es leute die benutzen
die lichtschalter und wenn du lichtschalter ausmachst kannst du deine rgb lampe nicht
mal einschalten weil sie ja der strom aus ist also wenn du es wenn man es wirklich richtig
richtig gescheit machen will müsstest du entweder deine lichtschalter austauschen gegen welche
die deine lampe ein ausschalten können über wähler oder aber du würdest dir das immer
wieder kaputt machen also die beste kombination ist wirklich du hast ein relay und an den
stellen wo du es brauchst noch trotz licht dimmbar die lampe weil dann kannst du es
über die über den über den schalter ein und ausschalten da musste deine rgb lampen
so einschalten dass sie quasi das letzte was eingestellt war wieder neu anmachen und
das könnte es können alle das können alle rgb lampe und dann kannst du es so machen
du steuerst das also du kannst ein und ausschalten war nach wie vor über den schalter und wenn
du es dann eingeschaltet hast und möchtest die farbtemperatur oder sonst was ändern
das musste dann halt übers web interface machen oder über die app oder was auch immer du
verwendest oder du nimmst noch einen weiteren schalter gibt es ja mittlerweile welche man
auch magnetisch irgendwo hin hängen kann für umschalten der lampen ergibt gibt milliarden
varianten wie man das machen kann also wirklich unzählbar was man wie man das machen kann
das ist auch das wichtigste und warum ich denke dass wenn man wenn man im thema heim
automatisieren was macht warum fertige lösungen nichts bringen weil das echt total individuell
ist wie man wie man es am liebsten hat und wenn man eine fertige lösung hat dann kriegt
man 80 prozent hin aber man wird nie es wirklich optimal für sich hinbekommen weil das die
fertigen lösungen einfach nicht bieten wenn man wenn man das selbst macht dann hast du
noch zusätzlich den vorteil du kannst es genauso machen wie du willst oder wie es
deine frau will freuen den wollen du kannst für die kinder richtig einstellen und du
hast den vorteil du bist nicht hersteller gebunden du kannst wenn du sowas wie home
assistant verwendest du kannst mehr oder weniger alle geräte miteinander kombinieren du musst
es nicht nur von einem hersteller machen nicht nur mit einer funk technologie es bietet
sich natürlich an sachen zu nehmen die auf ähnlicher technologie basieren dass man
jetzt nicht 50 sticks braucht aber es würde gehen ja ich habe es bei mir auch mittlerweile
so es ist ja über die zeit gewachsen ich habe sachen über wlan drinne ich habe sachen
über zig b drinne ich habe sachen über sie wave drinne ich habe sachen über decked drinne
ja über ganz normale netzwerkabel und über klassischen funk auf 433 megahertz nämlich
für die rollen alles integriert im home assistant und funktioniert zusammen was du so bei einer
fertigen lösung im leben nicht hinkrieg ja excellent excellent for misterion leider nicht
ich habe den hier aber ich habe keine ahnung ob der noch angesagt ist der liegt nämlich
so in dem preis aber ich glaube da ist alt mittlerweile ich habe mir den auch vor zwei
jahren oder sogar kauft doch bestimmt musste mal suchen also ich bin ja kein fan von aliexpress
für 230 voltgegäte allerdings wenn man diese dinger sich kauft von amazon kann man sich
die auch von aliexpress kaufen weil im ernst das ist der gleiche krab also man diese dinger
sich bei aliexpress bestellt bei amazon macht im endeffekt kein unterschied die haben die
haben ce zeichen aber die sind die sind wahrscheinlich ohne zu testen aufgedruckt wie bei dem ganzen
china kram das ist ja auch so ein ding was man sich selbst verleihen kann ich glaube
ce zeichen sagt ja nicht wirklich irgendwas aus also wie gesagt ich bin da kein großer
fan von aliexpress für 230 voltgeräte aber die dinger habe ich trotzdem und funktionen
gut wenn du es ein bisschen sicherer haben willst nimm dir den shelly nimm dir den shelly
shelly plug das ist zwar auch china chip aber ich hoffe mal ein bisschen besser qualität
kontrolliert so ich weiß gar nicht wie viel kosten die wie viel kosten so ein shelly plug
aktuell der kleine kokona was soll das jetzt mal ernsthaft warum ist der kokona plug kostet
nur die hälfte es sieht kacke aus ja optisch ist der hier
schon am besten aber was kosten vierer pack shelly 64 euro es geht ich meine man muss
sich mal überlegen hier kostet der vierer pack 65 euro bei amazon kostet halt 36 euro
für die china also es ist schon nicht ganz die hälfte aber es ist halt schon ein unterschied
und die kriegt man im angebot bei amazon teilweise noch noch günstiger kann man sich nehmen was
man was man was man lustig ist aber warum kostet warum kostet der kokona plug so wenig
er sieht hässlich aus ja ok er kann auch 230 volt ok warum ist er so viel billiger kann
man lgb bei den shelly stecker steuern du meinst was das für eine farbe hat hierin
keine ahnung ich habe einen shelly stecker aber der liegt in der box die hier kommen
mit das motor vom werk sieht fast so aus wie meine echt wo kann man die kaufen aliexpress
guck mal die chinesen die chinesen liefern schon den kram direkt mit aus excellent die
chinesen ok vier stück kostet 43 euro ok dafür sicher flashbar das doch schon mal
ganz gut ahja shipping standard shipping das geht bestimmt über eu wahrenlage das
nicht beim zoll hängen bleibt so finde ich interessant dass sie das schon preflesht haben
finde ich cool kannte kannte ich jetzt noch nicht du kannst ja danach einfach drüber
flaschen dann ist ruhe das finde ich cool gibt sie gibt sie auch bei da müssen wir
uns mal kurz gucken gibt sie auch bei banggood bei banggood ist manchen sachen so elektro
kram oftmals sogar noch einen ticken billiger darf ich mal fragen was du mit dem so einfach
so machst bin auf dich gestoßen ja ja kann ich dir sagen ich sag nur kurz nach der steckdose
suchen wir zwölf hier da ist da ist da auch schon das sick be what the fuck ja also was
was mache ich mit meinem server also sprichst du sprichst von diesem teil da unten da in
dem raum ist ja noch mehr also lass mal überlegen was habe ich auf dem server alles drauf ich
habe meine heim automatisierung drauf mit home assistant ich habe den wiki drauf ich
muss jetzt mal nachgucken ich habe so einen dashboard drauf was ich eigentlich überhaupt
nicht brauche ich habe einen pxe server drauf ich habe mein git web frontend zeug drauf
ich habe einen fileserver drauf ich habe so zehn sachen oder so drauf ungefähr eine
datenbank wo ich meine ganze hardware habe habe ich drauf trägst du in das wiki wirklich
was ein ja in dem wiki steht zum beispiel drinne wie ich das mit zertbot let's encrypt
mache wie ich das motor mqtt für home assistant einrichtet und sowas ja da schreibe ich wirklich
manchmal sachen rein ja shit meine ich shit shit welches wiki doku wiki was habe ich
denn da noch drauf ich weiß ach so ja ich habe noch eine pains jam nextcloud drauf aber
das sagt ich bin überhaupt kein nextcloud fan es ist alles es ist alles in über docker
compose bis auf meine heim automatisierung die habe ich umgezogen in ne vm weil die das
docker setup nicht mehr richtig supportet haben habe ich glaube scheiß drauf ziehe
sie ne vm um und seitdem funktioniert es ohne probleme hat auch noch einen weiteren großen
vorteil wenn ich ein update mache mache ich einfach vorher einen vm snapshot was für
eine hardware also was super billiges srock j4 1 sowas sowas hier in der richtung nicht
exakt das aber fast das ja und der kram kostet auch nicht viel 80 euro kostet das bord oder
noch billiger das bord habe ich hier aber aber nicht auch das ist die neue variante
aber ich habe das bord nur nur eine generation älter mit dem mit dem langen pizzi express
weil ich habe so gemacht in dem pizzi express ist eine 10 g ist eine 10 g netzwerkkarte
drin man kann sie nicht ganz mit 10 gigabit ansprechen weil der port selbst nur zweifach
angebunden ist ja und das ist tatsächlich ein ltp drucker port ist all school ja
so also habe ich irgendwas übersehen aber das ist interessant dass das die dass die
stade mich mit das motor kommen das finde ich echt cool was ja im endeffekt heißt also
moment ich ich gehe gerade mal kurz auf aliexpress das heißt ich würde hier erst
mal kurz überlegen also ich würde hier einen vierer pack kriegen jetzt kostet auf einmal
wieder mehr ane das ist hier der vierer pack am moment deutsch us dollar ne ne währung
währung euro die kommen sogar aus frankreich dann hast du sogar den versand dafür sogar
der versand geht schnell was ist das sechs stück sechs stück das ist sogar relativ
hey das geht das ist preislich gar nicht mal so schlecht guck mal du kriegst vor du kriegst
die vor installiertes china steckdose zum preis von der die du selbst flaschen müsstest und die
du aufmachen musst und ich flaschen kann hey das ist gar nicht mal so übel der sechser pack
den finde ich eigentlich recht recht sinnvoll warum ist es jetzt auf einmal wieder us dollar
ich habe doch hä warum ist das us dollar ich habe umgestellt auf euro
guck mal der ist sogar im angebot gerade ich check es nicht
ach die sind gerade im angebot ok hey das ist preislich echt nicht übel also würde ich steckdosen
brauchen die ich würde mir jetzt den sechser pack können die können die powermeter
wahrscheinlich nicht oder das sind die billigen steckdosen champ ja die offizielle app braucht
kein menschen also das wird dann auch über das motor gesteuert moment sind die sind die
überhaupt schon vor installiert ach nee moment das sind andere die vor installiert sind das hier
waren gar nicht die mit das motor alter das ist ja verwirrung pur chinesen wieder am start
können die könnig gucken wie viele geräte verbrauchen dahinter weil das finde ich immer
ganz nützlich sie haben zu kalibrieren energie meter ok das ist cool
hier steht kein tas motor drin aber das ist das ich würde ernsthaft das würde ich mir
wahrscheinlich sogar holen jetzt durch vier das würde ich mir wahrscheinlich sogar holen
also das klingt vor installiertes tas motor würde ich gleich das neueste drüber flaschen
und gut ist finde ich finde ich ist eigentlich eine ganz coole geschichte und wenn man glück
hat kommt das manche kam aus frankreich stand da manche kommen aus frankreich oder was auch
immer man weiß es nicht voraussicht die lieferung 11 april ok das ist halt das das ist halt das
ding wenn man in china bestellt aber interessant gut zu wissen dass es das gibt finde ich finde
ich nice ja man kann sich auch ein jelly kaufen bezahlt dann ungefähr ungefähr einen 40 prozent
mehr muss muss muss sich jeder selbst überlegen ja das stimmt motor hat den besten besten namen
der schenny door sensor sieht scheiße aus ja die door sensor sind meistens kacke aus ich
habe ich habe door sensor habe ich habe bei ich habe sieben door sensors mit fenster sensors
gekauft bei aliexpress für glaube 7 57 das stück als es beim angebot war für 60 prozent
reduziert davon habe ich mir klein zwanziger pack gekauft habe immer noch welche hier rumfliegen
aus gern fuchs 19 monate subscripte dankeschön für den sub ich weiß gar nicht was das schelle
vier pro ist ehrlich gesagt ich blick ich blick nämlich bei den bei den schelle produkten nicht
mal durch schelle vier ach das ist auf auf den leiste bonny keine ahnung genau also farbtemperatur
ist nice richtig rgb brauchen eigentlich die wenigsten
der auskern fuchs kennt sich mal wieder aus hatte recht der drucke der drucke mischt die
lampen scheinen selbst deswegen funktioniert das anders also subtraktiv heißt dass das was
der drucke macht es fällt licht auf das platt drauf die tinte absorbiert teile von dem licht
und das was zurückkommt ist das ist die farben die ihr sehen wollt die der drucke ausdruckt
additiv ist das was der monitor oder die lampe macht die leuchten selbst in den farben und das
mischt sich zusammen big brain stream wieder du hast die du du hast die die kleinen cellis die
die einser oder welche hast du ja die sind ganz schön fett aber bei mir passt auch unter die
dose links von den preflash hatte einer gerade vorhin in chat gepaust und ich finde jetzt auch
einer mehr irgendeiner hat es hier irgendwo gepostet vorhin vielleicht ist er noch da kann
man pausen die export saurei anzeige ist raus grüße an den alex t ja käme ich mal so weiter
also alex t huge grus von xt xt xt xt xt hatten wir schon
kommt drauf an was du machen willst wenn du eine köln module brauchst dann musst du
eine vm nehmen ja das ist aber nicht soll ich nicht so easy gewesen in dem fall weil
dieses home assistant docker setup besteht irgendwie aus drei oder vier verschiedenen
containern die du quasi zueinander passen snapshot muss die haben in superweiser container
den addon container den sonst was gefahrt mir nicht alles es ist nicht sonderlich easy gemacht
es ist in der vm tatsächlich einfacher in der vm snapshot ist so dass es werden irgendwie
alle zwölf container was die da am laufen haben gesnapschottet was ein upgrade wenn es abkackt
machst revert und ansonsten lässt es laufen also das ist in der vm definitiv einfacher
gab es wieder lustige produkt placement anfragen ja gibt es für permanent irgendwelche schienen
ja lords mobile sollte ich jetzt machen lords mobile solchen placement machen instagram
instagram post soll ich machen für lords mobile und ich habe überhaupt kein instagram
auf aliexpress immer im angebot das stimmt teilweise aber die die dinger wechseln tatsächlich
also diese 30 prozent ist oftmals wirklich zeitlich limitiert was aber bei aliexpress
also so ist es ist immer irgendwas davon im angebot also im zweifelsfall warte mal zwei
wochen dann kannst du wieder kaufen ja ich habe halt viele fenster ich habe allein schon
hier oben arbeitszimmer wohnzimmer bad küsche schlafzimmer vier wenn ich es nicht was
übersehen habe so dann habe ich unten zweimal küche wohnzimmer schlafzimmer bad tür und
im keller noch mal vier da bist du mit den 20 schon mehr oder weniger durch wenn du wirklich
jedes fenster und tür damit also jede also ich habe ja sogar nur die außen tür damit
ausgestattet die türen im haus überwache ich ja gar nicht ob die auf oder zu sind wo
zu das würde ich nur machen das würde ich nur machen wenn ich eine sinnvolle automatisierung
hätte aber habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht gefunden ich könnte zum beispiel ich könnte
nur mal so nur mal so ein beispiel was mir geradezu spontan einfällt wo man sieht was
man für coole sachen machen kann wenn man die sachen selbst macht und sich nicht so
sehr an einen hersteller bindet also was ich machen könnte zum beispiel ich könnte an
mein klo also an meine badezimmer tür könnte ich nen tür sensor hängen so und ich könnte
es jetzt automatisierungstechnisch so programmieren ich habe ja an der heise ich weiß ja auch
die temperatur von dem raum und ich habe wenn ich das wenn ich das möchte auch noch
eine thermostat an der heizung und was auch immer also ich könnte zum beispiel wenn ich
die tür zum badezimmer schließe könnte ich im endeffekt gucken wie ist die raumtemperatur
oder besser gesagt welche jahreszeit ist es und wie ist die raumtemperatur ich könnte
gucken ist das fernster auf ist das fernster zu wenn das fernster geschlossen ist und
raumtemperatur unter einem gewissen dingses könnte ich beispielsweise automatisch beim
schließen der badezimmer tür den heizlüfter anmachen oder sowas oder die heizung hoch
fahren lassen oder was auch immer also man kann auch schon coole sachen machen ja manchmal
manchmal versenden die aus frankreich niederlande spanien und so
mach doch einfach nen esp 866 magnet nee das bringt nix weil du die dinger auf batterie
laufen lassen musst oder die normalen esp 266 verbrauchen auch im deep sleep zu viel für
batterie du bräuchtest dann einen extra bord wo es dann wieder schwierig mit dem wake up
beim input ist also es tatsächlich hat es seine vorteile dort passende hardware zu verwenden
wer die umfrage gemacht ihr glaubt doch nicht dass sie den instagram account haben wollen
der fünf follow art die haben schlicht ergreifen einfach nur mal instagram angefragt weil
jeder heute ein instagram account hat außer ich anscheinend es hat keinen sinn leute chat
das ist nicht easy money die machen das einfach nicht hast du schon mal was von unrate gehört
ja habe ich aber ist nicht mein fall ich mache die sachen lieber selbst keine ahnung habe
ich noch mit diesen pcb vorlagen habe ich noch keine erfahrung habe ich noch nicht
selbst gemacht ich war mal kurz davor ob ich mir bei pcb way war es glaube ich so ein
eigenes bord mal designe aber habe ich zu wenig plan von und man hat nur so viel zeit
wie man zeit hat sachen zu lernen und zu machen ja
ist das problem mit diesen smart home sachen ist das kann niemand der nicht weiß wie es
funktioniert benutzen wenn man umziehen muss wenn ich also ich wohne im eigenen haus ich
habe eh nicht das problem aber wenn ich also wenn ich mal davon aus wenn ich noch in der
alten wohnung wohnen würde wo ich vorher gewohnt habe da würde ich an die wichtigsten
stellen auch ein zwei cellis machen die wird halt beim ausziehen wieder ausbauen das ist
ja gar kein großartiges ding ich hätte da kein großartiges bock kein großartigen bock
drauf und ich würde wahrscheinlich nicht jeden schalter in der mietwohnung im celli versorgen
aber dort wo mich wo mich persönlich nervt da würde ich das trotzdem machen alternativ
wenn es wenn es nur darum geht geräte zu schalten würde ich einfach einen zwischenstecker nehmen
also man kann auch in der mietwohnung viel machen ja mir war klar dass das gewinnt aber
ich kann es nicht ändern die werden das nicht machen leute da könnt ihr noch so viel voten
so viel noch so viel voten donaten subscribes giften by the way prime sub ist zurzeit günstiger
zusammen also es hat keinen sinn hat echt keinen also geht nicht funktioniert nicht
der war es also so so an die verse und tritt beim dankeschön für den sub
eigentlich war mir kein instagram instagram account habe ich heute nicht verstanden wozu
man instagram braucht oder du lässt die dinge einfach drinnen die cellis und sagst keinem
was weil es schränkt ja die funktion nicht eins und es geht auch nach wie vor ja wo sind
wir eigentlich stehen geblieben wollten wir nicht noch irgendwas gucken wollen wir wollen
wir sehen was anschauen tech fails und sich das zu gucken oder ist das war das der microsoft
nazibot oder bring ich jetzt nur durcheinander ok wir gucken das mal ich habe das ist ein
video was ein mod vorgeschlagen hat keine ahnung keine ahnung ob das was taugt aber
ich denke mal wattei wattei der nazibot von microsoft also es gab mal einen bot von microsoft
bevor er das zeigt ich weiß nicht ob das das war also microsoft hat mal einen bot programe
den twitter bot den twitter bot programmiert der ai mäßig quasi lernen sollte auf fragen
zu antworten so und ein paar im zweifelsfall war es wieder fortgen wenn so was passiert
ist es oftmals fortgen haben versucht den bot zu trainieren dass der irgendwelche anti
feministischen und nazi antworten gibt also die haben den bot quasi folge spammt mit
irgendwie zeug ja und dann hat der bot quasi auf die frage was weiß ich dann hat so ich
denke mir jetzt irgendwas aus dann hast du den bot gefragt zu irgendwie was sagst du
zu frauen und dann hat der bot gesagt quasi keine ahnung ich hasse ich hasse alle frauen
und irgendwie irgendwelche nazisachen ja also der hat der bot ist etwas in die hose
gegangen von microsoft er wollte ich übrigens mal ein extra video drüber machen weil ich
wollte mich damit ein bisschen mehr beschäftigen hat mir gedacht wenn du die wenn du das schon
mal anguckst kannst auch ein video drüber machen habe ich aber nicht gemacht ich finde
es aber ein echt interessantes thema und microsoft hat das ding wieder wieder eingestellt dann
nach ein paar tagen ok kommt mal mal
war das nicht so ist nicht das segway erfinder mit segway von der klippe gefallen war das
nicht war da nicht irgendwas oder oder ist es so eine so eine urban legend weiß gar nicht
wie man das ding schreibt erfinder klippe genau der segway erfinder ist mit segway von
der klippe gefahren dass ich das ist auch irgendwie nen man könnte sagen fast schon ein stylish
abgang für den segway erfinder nicht der der eigentümer der eigentümer ja segway gibt
es nicht mehr die waren vor elektroroller und und und haben versucht elektroroller zu
verbreiten und es hat nicht geklappt also schieß los das kann ja schon mal nicht funktionieren
ist laut genug oder soll ich bisschen lauter machen oh das war dave dave da kann ich mich
noch dran erinnern das das kommt mir noch bekannt vor
der
Er begann wirklich seltsam zu werden, wenn er dann wieder versucht hat, für ein zweites Mal.
Chloe, was ist heute Abend für Abendessen?
Ein fairer Spiel für den Mann auf der Bühne.
Er versuchte, es auszupacken, als ob der Roboter einfach angstig war.
Aber, als du...
Hast du einen Stream Deck? Nee, hab ich nicht. Stream Deck Overrated. Ich hab ein paar Elgato-Dinger, aber Stream Deck wüsste ich jetzt nicht, wozu ich das brauche. Stream Deck kann zum Beispiel nicht sowas hier machen. Ganz wichtig.
Okay, das Ding hat es halt ein bisschen verkackt, ja.
Aber, das Beste ist immer noch... Also da, wo ich mich früher übelst drüber kaputt gelacht habe, ist die Bill Gates Presentation.
Winner aus 95? Scanner?
Was? Crashed?
Das ist ein neuer Gerät. Und es wird in die entsprechenden Fahrzeuge geschüttelt. Du wirst bemerken, dass dieser Scanner...
Wir wundern uns, dass es das nicht in besserer Quali gibt. Das war ursprünglich auch nicht so schlecht.
Das ist ein neuer Gerät. Und es wird in die entsprechenden Fahrzeuge geschüttelt. Du wundern uns, dass es das nicht in besserer Quali gibt.
Und es wird in die entsprechenden Fahrzeuge geschüttelt. Du wundern uns, dass es das nicht in besserer Quali gibt.
Du wundern uns, dass es das nicht in besserer Quali gibt.
Du kannst dich einfach nicht. Du kannst dich einfach nicht darauf verlassen dass das irgendwie
Gewissenhaft gemacht ist beziehungsweise
Nicht nicht
Irgendwie was was drin ist was du halt nicht haben willst du weißt halt schlicht und ergreifend nicht bei solchen bei solchen cloud produkten
Und die hersteller sind ja alles andere als an transparenz interessiert bei sowas
Die im zweifelsfall wird sowas eher
Kleingeredet dass man nicht will dass es weil man nicht will dass es an die große klocke gehängt wird
Paniously bursting into flames so
Quite the duo i mean obviously this wasn't amazon's fault and they did address it with a software update but what a horrendous oversight
Okay, do you remember when segways and hoverboards were like the coolest thing on the planet?
How it finally felt like we figured out a solution to segways ich persönlich finde segways cool
Aber das hat sie nicht durchgesetzt
Well, we found out the hard way segways were dangerous you lose focus for just one second and you're either in a ditch a road or
You've already knocked someone over. Ja gut. Hey, das ist im auto auch so
So du musst halt gucken was du machst oder auf dem fahrrad oder sonst wo ich finde die dinger cool
Du musst halt gucken was wurde fest und was du machst
Even the president of the united states was seen falling off one of these and this right here shows when a cameraman
Managed to plow straight into usain bolt world's fastest sprinter or at least he was before that
Und das ist absurd das hat eigentlich auch mit urgentlyP Meer sucht zu landen im
However ist es nicht weiß ich nicht ganz noch Neptunen
Hier auf dem fahr mini ich binеди
Das glaube ich ihm nicht. Das hatte ich gerade ausgedacht.
Was mir nicht geholfen hat, ist, dass viele von diesen hoffnungsvollen Boarden, die ehrlich gesagt nur Boarden waren,
angefangen haben zu kämpfen.
Hälfte von Millionen von ihnen mussten wiederholt werden.
Das ist genug, um irgendwelche möglichen zukünftigen Produkte zu zerstören.
Also, das ist definitiv ein 7 von 10 Territory.
Und das lässt uns mit ein paar großen sozialen Medienverlusten
zu den großen Nr. 1.
Und wir beginnen mit unseren guten Freunden auf Facebook.
Ok, es ist 2018. Facebook hatte eine der größten Datenverlusten aller Zeiten,
die 50 Mio. User verletzten.
Nicht zu erwähnen, die größte Tech-Scam der Dezember,
in der die User-Daten von Facebook ausgestattet wurden,
um politische Advertisse zu benutzen.
Was für eine tolle Zeit, um einen massiven Facebook-Branded-Always-On-Camera-Screen- und Mikrofon
in den Häusern zu sitzen.
Ok. Kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern, scheint es nicht lange gemacht zu haben.
Hast du einen Facebook-Account? Ja.
Auf dem Facebook-Account steht aus irgendwelchen Gründen,
passt mal auf, ich bin mir selbst nicht so sicher, warum das da steht.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen steht da, dass ich powered by Alienware bin.
Ich weiß nicht warum. Ich kann mich nicht mehr dran erinnern,
dass ich jemals powered by Alienware war.
Ich wollte mal, ich wollte mal, ich wollte mal mit denen was machen.
Da ist es aber nie dazu gekommen.
Vielleicht habe ich das geändert nach dem Motto, guckt mal, so könnte es aussehen.
Ähm...
Keine Ahnung, benutzen denn andere noch ihren Facebook-Account?
Nee.
Facebook benutzt doch eh kein Mensch mehr.
Warum machst du denn das Alienware nicht weg?
Da müsste ich mich einloggen und da kriegen alle eine Nachricht,
dass ich das Banner geändert habe und...
Tomtricks, danke schön für den Sub.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Dieser Facebook-Datenskandal und der Umgang, das war eines der wenigen Dinge, wo ich echt das Gefühl hatte,
es hatte Auswirkungen drauf.
Vielleicht weil es auch einer der ersten richtig großen in dieser Art und Weise war,
bei einem richtig großen Anbieter.
Mittlerweile sind die Leute so abgehärtet, das juckt einfach kein mehr.
Ach wie, zwei Millionen Kunden Daten verloren, auch egal, YOLO, ihr kriegt weiter mal ein Zeug.
Aber Facebook ist ja mittlerweile nur noch bei irgendwelchen Boomer-Leuten am Start,
die da unlustige Sachen posten.
Das letzte Mal an Ostern habe ich echt das...
cringigste, den cringigsten Boomer-Facebook-Post aller Zeiten gesehen.
Was mich mal wieder dazu gebracht hat, dass Facebook echt noch nie meine Welt war
und die Leute, die da sind, wirklich nichts mit zu tun haben.
Da hat einer auf Facebook gepostet, sind zu Ostern, an Ostern sucht man keine Eier, man spielt mit Eier.
Und so ein doofes Emoji drunter, das war so ein ultra dummer Boomer-Post, so ein richtiger Pains-Champ-Post.
Das ist so ein typischer dummer Facebook-Boomer-Gruppen-Post, alter.
Richtig cringe.
Seitdem habe ich Facebook nie wieder aufgemacht.
Also, ich habe Facebook auch vorher nie aufgemacht, aber nicht mal das Besuchergebnis, dann klicke ich es noch an.
Könnte mein Vater sein.
Theoretisch meiner auch, vom Alter her.
Facebook ist mittlerweile nicht mal wirklich Boomer-Book,
weil Boomer ist ja mittlerweile heute fast schon jeder über 30 oder über 35.
Facebook ist 60 plus Book mittlerweile.
Er sagte, wir wollen definitiv keine Gesellschaft, wo es eine Kamera im Wohnzimmer gibt.
Und während wir da sind mit Facebook, erinnert man sich vielleicht an den jahrzehntlosen WhatsApp-Update.
Sie kamen komplett aus Blut mit einer Notifikation, die gesagt hat, dass ihre Terms für die Service gestartet worden sind.
Und wisst ihr was sich ändern wird? Nix.
Sie könnten das ein bisschen besser erwähnen.
Was uns hierher kam, war, dass diese Notifikation WhatsApps Daten mit Facebook teilen durfte.
Und die Leute waren furchtbar.
Weil, natürlich, die Bedeutung war, dass, auch wenn man denkt, dass man einen privaten Chat mit jemanden hat,
diese Daten nicht nur nicht privat sind,
sondern sie werden sogar noch mehr schrecklich akkuereiert werden.
Aber wer vorher davon ausgegangen ist, dass in einem private WhatsApp-Chat die Sachen wirklich private sind,
dem kann ich auch nicht helfen.
Ja, aber es wird sich aber nichts ändern.
Die Leute gehen jetzt zu alternativen Messagern, stellen fest, da ist keine Sau, und gehen wieder zurück zu WhatsApp.
WhatsApp sagt, es hat End-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselungen.
Alles, was man bisher gesehen hat, scheint das auch so zu sein.
Aber wer weiß, ob morgen ein Update gepusht wird, wer weiß, ob da nicht doch irgendwo eine Hinterhütte drin ist.
Du hast keine Ahnung im Endeffekt.
Und kannst du nicht haben, wenn du solche Plattformen verwendest.
Letztendlich, man kommt an so ein Third-Party-Plattform, du kommst heute nicht mehr dran vorbei,
du kannst dein Leben nicht komplett ohne mehr führen, oder zumindest schlecht.
Aber man kann es auch übertreiben, also man muss auch nicht bei jeder Sache mitmachen und da sein Zeug scheren.
Gibt's Knudels noch?
Welchen Messenger benutzt du hauptsächlich?
Discord für die Arbeit Teams.
Und ich hab Signal installiert, aber nur, weil wir da mal eine Gruppe auf der Arbeit hatten.
Und hat mich gleich wieder dazu gebracht, dass ich diesen ganzen Kack nicht will.
Die machen ja ein bisschen auf...
Privacy und sowas.
Und das erste, was passiert ist, dass mich zwei Tage später kommt ein Büro jemand und meint,
hey Max, du bist jetzt auch bei Signal.
Dann sag ich, hä?
Woher weißt du das denn?
Und dann meinte er, ja, ich hab ne Benachrichtigung bekommen, dass du dir jetzt angemeldet hast.
Einfach so, ich hab extra am Anfang gesagt, ich bin jetzt bei Signal.
Einfach so, ich hab extra am Anfang gesagt, ich will meine Kontaktdaten nicht scheren.
Also totaler Rotz.
Lass mal überlegen, was könnten denn die ersten Fails, also Stadia haben wir schon.
Also Google Plus, Google Plus ist auf jeden Fall mit dabei.
Bei den Top Fails.
Google Plus muss dabei sein.
Chat, was fällt euch denn so ein?
Es gab jede Menge Fails, aber so spontan, es gibt so viele.
Spontan fällt mir da gar nicht so viel ein jetzt.
Also wie gesagt, Google Plus muss dabei sein, das geht gar nicht anders.
Ja, mal gucken.
Windows Phone, ja das hat ja nichts funktioniert.
Also Google Plus ist auf jeden Fall dabei.
Internetausbau in Deutschland.
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab Rewind noch nie geguckt.
War das das, wo sie PewDiePie nicht einladen wollten aus irgendwelchen Gründen?
Irgendwo wurden sie doch mal richtig hardcore geflamed.
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Die Xbox One war bei Release auch ein Fail.
Der hat ja sehr viel mit YouTube zu tun.
Ja, das frag ich mich auch.
Wir haben ja auch unser eigenes Cringe-Format.
Kennt noch jemand diesen Videopreis, diesen deutschen Dingster Videopreis?
Ich hab vergessen, wie der heißt.
Diese Schwachsinnveranstaltung?
Warte mal, was war das denn?
Was war denn das nochmal?
Die haben halt, glaube ich, alle noch nicht gecheckt, dass gerade viele Jüngere, die
wollen gar nicht mehr so sehr klassischen und auch von irgendwelchen Studios produzierten
Content sehen.
Ich meine, warum ist denn TikTok so erfolgreich?
Guckt euch mal an.
Bei uns versuchen ja auch die ganzen Öffentlich-Rechtlichen jetzt mit irgendwelchen YouTube-Channels,
die sie sich entweder einkaufen, Corporations machen oder neu gründen, irgendwas auf die
Reihe zu kriegen.
Da sind ein paar ganz gute Sachen ab und zu dabei, aber zum größten Teil ist es hoffnungslos.
Wir versuchen, ein paar Leute zu erreichen, die uns halt auf unserer klassischen Plattform
komplett abhanden gekommen sind.
Ja, die sehen ja auch vom Alter her exakt so aus, als wissen die, was junge Leute gucken
wollen.
Genau.
Ja, ganz vergessen, das interessiert die Leute heutzutage immer weniger.
Und wenn das mit Streaming so weitergeht und mit diesem, jedes Studio macht einen eigenen
Premium-Channel, bin ich mir sicher, ob es so diese globalen Stars in dieser Sache überhaupt
noch geben wird.
Wenn du dir überlegst, Disney hat was eigenes, Amazon macht eigenes Zeug, Netflix macht mittlerweile
jeder was eigenes.
Jeder hat dann quasi eigene Sendung, eigene Shows, eigene bekannte Leute.
Ob es so wirklich dann auch so wirklich so was wie Michael Jackson mal gibt oder so, den
quasi auf der ganzen Welt jeder kennt, weiß ich nicht, ob es das in Zukunft bestimmt
noch vereinzelt, ja, aber aber wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so irgendwie 500 Leute oder so.
Quibi hat man das ausgesprochen.
Schreckt.
Okay, das hätte ich jetzt nicht so mir vorgestellt.
Stimmt, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Ja, ja, ich erinnere mich.
Meiner, meiner nicht, meiner nicht.
Genau, ich erinnere mich.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Ja.
Ja, klar.
Welche Gruppe von Masterminds kamen mit dieser Sache an?
Drei Teenager.
Und freundlich wollten sie alles, um schnelles Geld zu verdienen.
Denn wenn das von jemanden gemacht wurde, mit malisierteren Intentionen,
mit dieser Art von Macht,
die Fähigkeit, auf der Bedeutung von jemandem in der Welt zu sprechen,
kannst du eine Waffe beginnen.
Also, 8 von 10 verfehlt für diese.
Nun, in jeder Liste von Tech-Fail...
Weiß man denn heute, wie wir dies geschafft haben?
...2021, wir können nicht über Cyberpunk reden.
Für diejenigen, die es nicht wissen,
ist das das größte Video-Game...
...der der ganze Jahr.
Sie haben es nur ein paar Monate zurück veröffentlicht, aber...
...sind es seit 2013.
Und klar, wenn es so revolutionär ist,
warten wir 7 Jahre, nachdem wir den ersten Trailer gesehen haben.
Aber das war es nicht.
Und ich denke, niemand hätte erwartet,
wie schrecklich es sich backführen würde.
In einem best-case-Szenario,
hast du eine schmutzige Messe.
Wir reden von randomen Teleportationen,
verdammt grafischen Glitches,
Menschen fliegen durch Wälder,
und fast alles andere, was du davor denken kannst.
Aber noch schlimmer ist,
wenn du dieses Spiel auf einer Last-Gen-Playstation 4 oder Xbox One gekauft hast,
was, ich denke, die meisten Leute haben,
dann sah es und rannte.
Etwa so gut wie ich, nachdem Uber Eats 50% ausging.
Und es ist nicht nur das Fakt,
dass, als dieses Spiel ausgel,
das ist das Fakt, das kennen wir ja alle noch.
... CD Projekt Red,
sie versuchten, es zu verstecken.
Sie bestätigten den Zugang zu frühen Kopien,
sodass die Reviewer nicht noch jemanden bemerken konnten.
Du kannst dir wohl vorstellen,
dass, wenn alle Entwickler...
Sie wurden auf sozialen Medien zerstört.
Sie hatten mehrere Klasse-Aktions-Lawsuiten,
die gegen sie gefilmt wurden.
Aber das Schlimmste ist,
diese Leute wurden schrecklich hackt.
Und es ist schwer zu sagen,
ob das mit dem Spiel verbunden ist oder nicht.
... aber es wäre eine riesige Verletzung,
wenn es nicht wäre.
Jemand kam in ihren Serven
und nahm alles, was sie dachten,
...
Cyberpunk ist das größte Video-Game-Disaster,
Ja, ich finde es ab.
iPhone-Subscription.
Ja, stell dir mal vor.
Also ich wäre auch gleich in Keller.
Es muss, okay, Google Plus ist bis jetzt noch nicht gekommen.
Es muss Google Plus sein, Leute. Google Plus muss auf der 1 sein.
Postchamp.
So, Nummer 1.
Und das ist das erste Mal, dass ich einen Fehler gewonnen habe.
Alles über eine 9 von 10.
Okay, das stimmt. Warum war da Google Plus nicht drin? Okay, die haben es aber auch verdient. Die haben es auch verdient. Vor allem, dass sie wirklich Leute damit getestet haben und auf einmal Leute angeblich irgendwie, was weiß ich, einen Gehirntumor hatten, die vollkommen gesund waren und sowas. Ey, Alter, Alter.
Das ist die, das ist die, die versucht hat immer so tief zu sprechen in irgendwelchen Interviews.
Das hat aber nicht funktioniert.
Das Problem, finde ich, ist gar nicht mal so sehr, dass es nicht funktioniert hat.
Das ist natürlich so das grundlegende Problem, aber das Problem ist eher, dass diese komplette Kette versagt hat. Ich meine, die haben ja ernsthaft Leute damit getestet und haben dann gesagt, sie sind todkrank, obwohl sie nichts hatten.
Die haben gesagt, dass es in der Militär gearbeitet wurde und dass es in der Öffentlichkeit gearbeitet wurde, aber es hat es nicht.
Diese Theranos-Kompanie, sie haben nicht selbst diese Maschinen benutzt.
Sie sagten diesen Investoren, ja, klar, wir können euch eine Demo von unserer Technik geben.
Und sie würden ihre Blutsamplen nehmen, in eine Backrunde gehen und es mit konventionellen Methoden testen, zurückkommen und sagen, dass ihre Maschinen fertig sind.
Wenn man eine Maschine benutzt, um ihre Blutresultate zu bekommen, ist sie sehr wahrscheinlich missdiagnostiert. Und wenn du denkst, dass es schwer ist, wenn du dir gesagt hast, dass du Cancer hast, wenn du es nicht hast, oder wenn du dir gesagt hast, dass du es nicht hast, wenn du es tust, ist das schlimm.
So schlimm ist es, dass die ganze Kompanie geschlossen wird, so schlimm ist es, dass Elisabeth Homes auf Trial ist, so schlimm ist es, dass es eine gewinnene Dokumentarie, die über ihr Schlamm gemacht wurde, und sogar anscheinend eine ganze Feature-Filme in der Arbeit mit Jennifer Lawrence als sie gespielt hat.
Ich denke, das ist wertvoll von einem 10 von 10.
Okay, als ich diese Satz beendet habe, habt ihr gesehen, dass ich meinen eigenen Thai-Green-Curry gemacht habe.
Das ist es.
Du bekommst deinen Heupowder, wickelst es in Wasser, riechst es und lasst es...
Also wenn ich Thai-Curry essen will, dann noch nicht als Pulver.
Okay, okay, das muss nicht sein.
Das muss nicht sein.
Braucht man dafür auch so eine extra Presse, dass man das rauspressen kann?
Das ist für 700 Euro.
Leute, ich habe übeles Kohlenampf.
Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt...
Guck mal, ich bin länger on gewesen als sonst, obwohl ich Kopfweh habe.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, den man hosten kann?
Ist da Frazier am Start?
Sag mal, wen kann ich hosten?
Frazier ist nicht am Start, okay.
Ich gucke mal kurz in meine Followlist, ob irgendjemand dabei ist.
Keiner da.
Ich kenne ihn nicht.
Nee, keiner da, den ich kenne.
Leute, schön, dass so viele dabei gewesen sind.
470 Leute, huge Poggers.
Wir sehen uns, macht's gut.
Nächsten Stream.
Wer nicht gefollowed hat und ihm das gefallen hat, ich mache jeden Sonntag so einen Stream,
dann könnt ihr eine Runde followen.
Ihr könnt auch mal auf YouTube, Twitter vorbeigucken und Sellout beendet.
Wir sehen uns, bis dann.
Ich gehe was essen.
Also, macht's gut.
Tschüss.